on the balcony at Buckingham Palace they
will actually though they have been
invited they arrived in the UK yesterday
they have been invited by her majesty to
view the trooping of the color uh from
one of the balconies there at the parade
ground and there will also be at St
Paul's tomorrow as what we're being told
for the Thanksgiving appearance looking
at those pictures of horse guards as we
chat to you just also to mention that we
are expecting
um a third appearance by her majesty
today and that will be around about 9 30
this evening she will be at Windsor
Castle and she will be lighting the
first beacon of three and a half
thousand which will be lit around the UK
and also around the Commonwealth now how
is she going to light a beacon from
Windsor that is outside Buckingham
Palace well let me tell you it's the
tree of trees which you'll be lighting
it's a living sculpture and it
represents a tree planting throughout
the Queen's green carpet
um it's the principal Beacon and it's
got 350 British grown trees on it a lot
of LED lights as well Prince William
will be overseeing that to make sure
everything goes as planned and the queen
will be pressing a button and the LA LED
lights will come on and then we will see
beacons lit right around the country as
I said as well as other places around
the world some of the places that we
will see uh beacons being lit are on top
of Ben Nevis also on top of Snowden also
on top of scafell Pike
and we're also going to see BT Tower and
The Shard lit up as well along with 54
Commonwealth Capital Cities and
commonwealth countries also paying their
respects by lighting a beacon to Mark
the 70th anniversary of a platinum
Jubilee Channel Islands Isle of Man
let's not forget them they're taking
Parts in events as well
so that's uh all just for today I've not
even gone on to tomorrow yet and the
service of Thanksgiving which is taking
place at uh Saint Paul's Cathedral
when it comes to Saint Paul's Cathedral
we are expecting her majesty to attend
the we were expecting the sermon from
the Archbishop of Canterbury sadly he
has covid and also a touch of pneumonia
and so as a result not only can he not
light his Beacon at Lambeth Palace
tonight but he also will not be able to
take the sermon on the service of
Thanksgiving later on on tomorrow around
about uh half ten eleven o'clock of
course we'll bring that to you live as
well here on Sky News
when it comes to Saturday we were
initially expecting the queen to go to
Epsom for the races uh we're now being
told that that is not really likely and
instead she is likely to be meeting Lily
bit lillybet is her youngest great great
grandchild the daughter of Harry and
Megan and she will be one year old on
Saturday the queen has not met her yet
so our understanding is that that is
probably what she is going to be doing
I'm going to pause again now then you
can see more of the military and the
military pageant here
have a look here
foreign
and you'll be able to enjoy all of
trooping the color with Sarah Jane in
just a moment or two but before we do
that I'm just going to go and chat to
some more people in the crowd the police
won't let me down so what I'm going to
do is lean over the top and see what
people thought hello again everybody did
you see that
how cool is that amazing wasn't it we've
got 30 seconds left on the program would
you like to sing the national anthem
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
glorious
[Music]
birthday
oh that was amazing
[Music]
[Applause]
hello good morning you're watching Sky
News live from Buckingham Palace and our
special coverage of the Queen's Platinum
Jubilee the 96 year old Queen is
celebrating 70 years as Monarch with
millions of people across Britain
gathering for Street parties in her
honor or the staging of this event is
immense down here at Buckingham Palace
events are well underway we're going to
be seeing the trooping the color shortly
also known of course as the Queen's
birthday parade after that a fly pass
which will be witnessed by the royal
family on the balcony of Buckingham
Palace behind me
and later in the day more than 2 000
towns Villages and cities across the
country and the Commonwealth there will
be a beacon lit to mock the Queen's
Reign it will be quite the spectacle
with stages set for a special moment in
history a platinum Jubilee uh something
that no Malik in this country has
celebrated before it truly is an
historic occasion
you can see here a lot of the
preparations getting underway trooping
the color we have our role commentator
Alistair Bruce to take us through
proceedings all the Pomp and ceremony
you can watch it unfold right here on
Sky News the crowds have been Gathering
since early this morning I arrived on
set at around seven o'clock this morning
which was quite early to come on here at
10 A.M and there were crowds streaming
down the mall to come in here to witness
what will be unfolding on day one of
four days of celebrations
foreign
[Music]
earlier today a new official photograph
of the queen was released ahead of these
celebrations to Mark her Platinum
Jubilee the portrait was taken in the
Victoria vestibule at Windsor Castle
earlier on this year the Queen's private
apartment inside Windsor Castle speaking
to the nation she said thank you to
everyone who has been involved in
convening communities families neighbors
and friends to mark my Platinum Jubilee
in the United Kingdom and across the
Commonwealth I know that many happy
memories will be created at these
festive occasions I continue to be
inspired by the Goodwill shown to me and
hope that the coming days will provide
an opportunity to reflect on all that
has been achieved during the last 70
years as we look to the future with
confidence and enthusiasm
well we just hear the sound of the band
fading away behind us as they leave
Buckingham Palace to head down the mall
I'm joined here in the studio by our
Royal corresponder Brianna Mills and of
course Vice guys we're all commentator
Alistar Breezy has a busy few days we
both have a busy few days ahead of you
and we're going to be joined by none
other than Dame Joanna lomley as well
from 12 o'clock today really looking
forward to that
um so here we are so much preparation it
is underway the crowds are assembled you
can hear the sort of Ripple of Applause
the laughter Alistar it really is
um a very important but also a very
happy occasion down here today oh it's
fabulous I mean this is what Britain
does best and the training that's gone
into this I've seen members of the royal
family arriving just over there at the
side of the palace being brought in by
the Motorcycle protection teams and then
we're seeing the streetliners I've just
seen five half companies make their way
up to be Mull and they form a sort of
wonderful red line down each side of the
mouth so that when the parade really
gets going it's properly marshaled and
protected talk about bands that we keep
playing in the background well they're
all making their way up to horse guards
where they'll form the mass bands of the
household Division and when they're all
together this is just sections of them
the sound is truly magnificent and it's
what I think over the years the
centuries has been part of the moral
component to make soldiers feel great
about who they are particularly at Great
Moments in their training and on this
occasion when for the queen this is a
really special day it's the anniversary
not only of her Platinum Jubilee
celebration but also of her coronation
in 1953 went exactly the same area was
full of scarlet and gold for that
celebration
we'll here come another and swathe of
the band very Rousey
the crowd very much enjoying this
because this is only just the start
Rihanna we haven't even got in uh to the
formal uh part of proceedings yet can
you talk to us about what have been
happening happening behind the scenes
and we just told Alice to say there that
the royal family have been arriving
through the side gate of Buckingham
Palace so what will be going on in the
palace right now
to make sure that everything looks
perfect because that is going to be
where all eyes are at about one o'clock
this afternoon because that's going to
be the second occasion that we're going
to see the queen alongside other working
members of the royal family but I think
also what is lovely is the fact that now
it's been confirmed as alistair's juking
around to the music it's now been
confirmed that we're going to see the
queen on three separate occasions so
they've slightly altered what they
normally do with trooping the color to
make sure that she can also take a
salute as the troops head back here to
Buckingham Palace and also of course
we'll see her with her family members
and then this evening at Windsor she is
going to start off what is going to be
this spectacular Beacon lighting
ceremony so the queen very much front to
the center today but plans adjusted of
course because she is now 96 years old
we know that she's had a bit of trouble
walking recently but clearly as the
palace have kept telling us she has been
really looking forward to this weekend
and wants to be involved as much as
possible
[Music]
at Alistair as we watch these fantastic
scenes uh down the mall talk to us about
what we could expect from trooping the
color this is something that marks the
the Queen's birthday every year
particularly special in this Platinum
Jubilee year
I can see you both leaning in to look at
those cars there who's inside them
is it the principle I think it's
probably the Prince of Wales come here
now he's going to be representing the
queen yes that's the Prince of Wales or
is it the Duke of Kent it's quite
difficult to tell with my eyesight I've
just put my glasses on I'm trying to see
but they'll be passing their way into
the palace all the Royal Colonels the
Duke of Kansas Colonel of the Scott
scars the Prince of Wales is Colonel of
the Welsh guards and the Duke of
Cambridge is the colonel of the Irish
glass they'll be joined by the Princess
Royal whose Colonel of the Blues and
Royals part of the household Cavalry
today she's playing the part of gold
stick in Waiting which means that she is
responsible for the security of the
queen on occasions like this so no one a
better mess with the Princess Royal
today very much so very much so and yeah
as we look at those cars assembly
because we are due to get underway
shortly and Alistair just for those
watching at home what can they expect to
see from trooping the color tripping the
color is a wonderful military tradition
whereby a color which in this case is
the Queen's color of the first Battalion
Irish guards will be first of all
unveiled on Parade it will then be
saluted and taken to the escort for the
color who will then receive it they will
become the escort from being for the
color to the color they will then treat
troop it through all the other guards
present there will be six overall on
horse guards and this gives every
Soldier the chance to identify this
symbol of the regiment
pride and respect and they know
therefore what it looks like and where
it is so that if there's a battle they
can protect it that was the tradition
behind it but what we're really seeing
today is a massive Changing of the Guard
because the escort for the color that
will have the color finally escort to
the color will then become the Queen's
guard here at Buckingham Palace and
protect her majesty when she's here at
the course at the palace and so much
preparation goes into trooping the color
of Rhiannon and so much preparation has
gone into the planning for these four
days it's amazing yeah it does look
incredible here and but we saw um Prince
William at the rehearsals on Saturday
how much is he going to be involved over
the coming days I think we are going to
very subtly in some ways see the queen
showing us that she has great faith in
her family and her heirs and the future
of the monarchy so that line of
succession and increasingly of course as
the queen has said I'm having a
difficult day not walking terribly well
today we have seen younger members of
the family stepping up and
stepping into that role on her behalf
and so we're going to see I think quite
a lot of that this weekend for moments
that she feels unable to attend
um but also for example The Beacon
Lighting she's not going to be here
herself when she said speaking off in
Windsor the principal Beacon is lit up
here and it's going to be the Duke of
Cambridge who's going to be there making
sure that everything goes to plan and
also today taking the salute on horse
guards parade is going to be the Prince
of Wales but also the palace making it
very clear supported by the Duke of
Cambridge and the Princess Royal and so
it's all about showcasing the family is
very secure they all know what role is
expected of them is that a police yeah
looking into the road yeah we seem to
have a couple of people interrupted yeah
the parade there they've rushed in
now the police will be very worried
about the soldiers in this situation
we've got to remember that it's an
interesting time in the world and people
who are of course in a democracy and for
us to come and enjoy this or Express
their views at it but we do know that
the security here because members of the
royal family coming down shortly there
will be concern to make sure that
soldiers are safe it huge job isn't it
for the security services well there are
thousands of people absolutely in the
mail as we speak and they want to make
sure that this occasion is seen to be as
open as possible I was on guard when
somebody fired at the queen with a
starting pistol and he was called Mr
sergeant and my Corporal Corporal Alex
Galloway grabbed the shooter and pulled
him over the barricade and laid into him
with his boots actually I think by the
time the police turned up he was begging
for the police to take lance corporal
Galloway off him but you know soldiers
will do whatever they can to protect the
queen but I know that the police here
have principal responsibility for
security and of course that is an issue
which will need to be managed as
carefully as they always do yeah but the
police have acted there quickly to it
looks like two protesters have managed
to gain access to that procession on the
map The Mao police quick to act but what
you're seeing around that is the lying
out of the streetliners and very shortly
see the first of the guards coming up
but not until all the streetliners
arrived I think this is the next lot we
will put this red line right underneath
the flags the full length of the mull
well a slightly interrupted Interruption
to proceedings their protesters are
interrupting that in the mail in fact as
you're talking Alice Reggie said that we
can just see uh more of the band uh
coming behind us to to head down the
mall um Aleister what are you most
looking forward to this weekend
I think that all of it will have its own
moment but I think for the queen that
moment when she goes to some pools if
she does indeed confirm her attendance
because that's a very peaceful moment
before God which is similar to that that
took place in 1953 when she obligated
herself as Sovereign at her coronation
and we heard earlier on from the
Archbishop of Canterbury how much of
that ceremony is both looking to the
future but also to those obligations
that the queen made under oath when she
became Queen at the start of her ring
it's 69 years ago today that her
coronation took place and of course
she'd been already Queen for more than
18 months we have more arrival shots
here cars sweeping past they're
literally just below us there heading in
uh different members of the royal family
all Gathering as I say because
those who are working members of the
royal family will be taking part in the
procession and also those who are
Colonels of the various regiments will
be in uniform and on Parade
Rhiannon
it's been very clear that the appearance
on the balcony at Buckingham Palace will
be for working members of the royal
family so it may not be as crowded as
we've seen in recent years but when will
we get opportunities to see other
members of the family the royal family
as a whole if you like
[Applause]
we see the bands walk past
well it's lovely for the soldiers too
you know they put a lot of work into
this and it has been you know this is
the culmination of it they've had two
big previous parades called reviews one
in front of their Major General who
terrifies them all and also one in front
of the Duke of Cambridge who's Colonel
of the Irish guards but this is what
it's for because this is for the queen
who is their colonel in Chief and also
she is the head of the Armed Forces
I think we'll hear another Ripple of
Applause as they disappear from view but
once again
these are those will be taking part in
the great ceremony later on
[Applause]
[Music]
preparation years in fact Alistair and
uh today is a very big occasion and of
course the next time that these crowds
will see the troops is when they return
back here and we see the queen taking
the salute on Buckingham Palace but as
you were saying earlier of course
everyone is waiting for the balcony
moment don't forget for two years
trooping the color was trimmed right
back and took place within the grounds
at Windsor Castle so we haven't seen a
balcony like this since 2019 but I think
for the queen there was obviously a huge
amount of speculation after everything
that's gone on within the family whether
or not we'd see the Duke and Duchess of
Sussex on the balcony and whether or not
we'd see Prince Andrew the queen last
month quite quick it was a difficult
decision we're told but she very clearly
stated and I think to try and end some
of that speculation that it was going to
be working Royals who would be alongside
her and I think you've got a couple of
things going on there I think she didn't
want that to be too much for distraction
with the Duchess of Cornwall
the Prince of Wales will be representing
Her Majesty the queen at horse guards
and taking the salute get by the
household division to her majesty on
this uh official birthday
and both the prince Wales and The
Duchess of Cornwall in the build up to
the Platinum Jubilee have been already
already getting involved in in various
different ways for marking this 70 years
on the throne so for example most
recently we were in Canada with the
couple and we heard the Prince Wells
there talking movingly about his mother
and her amazing commitment to service
and Duty and also hinting at how younger
members of the family are following and
I'm just going to interrupt you there
because we're going to bring everyone
live shots of Downing Street this is the
prime minister Boris Johnson preparing
to leave Downing Street to head down
here to the mile and Buckingham Palace
chief of the defense staff and all the
chiefs of the five eyes countries the
United Kingdom the United States Canada
Australia and New Zealand the five eyes
as they're known who share intelligence
and who work collectively for the
security of the world Kingdom
I spoke to a former Chief of the defense
staff who actually talked about previous
jubilees and how wonderful it is when
you hold that position to be able to
invite others from around the world to
come and witness what we have and they
said that actually the American
counterpart remarked on only you guys
can do this only you can do it to this
level and uh and so yeah wonderful
occasion for us to show to the world
this spectacular military pageantry yeah
Alistair I spoke to Carol Betteridge um
former Army officer on the Sky News
Daily podcast for a special Jubilee
Edition and she was awarded by the queen
and she said that she calls her or
everyone calls her the boss
well she is you know the wonderful thing
about the queen is she holds all power
she is the source of all power on behalf
of the Constitutional settlement which
actually sees Parliament as Sovereign
but she hands out that power never
carries it out herself but in essence
you know this role of a head of state
who is non-political provides a forum
for the political process to take place
under her
Supreme oversight really and you know
she's been doing it for 70 years and
she's met a large number of prime
ministers remember her first prime
minister was Sir Winston Churchill and
so she has a breadth of experience from
talking to so many of them and can
provide that perhaps every time she
meets her current prime minister which
is pretty much every week
I've
and she keeps a very active interest in
the Army Navy and Royal Air Force of
course and we will be having a fly past
joined the army of course she joined the
auxiliary territorial service at her
father's encouragement in the last year
of the war was she the first serving
female
member of the royal family yes uh there
have been of course members of the royal
family who are female who'd taken on
Colonel C appointments but the queen
actually went on her course became a
truck driver and learned how to support
the logistic effort of the United
Kingdom as it tried to make sure that it
defeated those who were the Axis powers
and you know for the queen
she recognizes exactly what it's like to
be on Parade like this she knows how to
March she's got eyes like lasers and
she's been sharpening those lasers for
70 years of her time as Queen and I
think she knows the burden that every
single time a soldier sailor a man or
woman goes into danger they're doing it
in her name for this country and when
there are casualties she's one of the
first people to be told and that's quite
a burden and Aleister Rihanna we just
saw a certain four-legged friend that
was on the breakfast show with you in
Cape early earlier on today the mascot
to the Irish guards
there he is Sheamus getting his big
moment
Sheamus is letting us know that he's
leading the escort for the color who
will be behind this band of course
that's the Irish guards band too and
they are taking their escort for the
color up to horse guards and they will
later on be trooping the color of the
first Battalion Irish guards in front of
the queen but look at that happy dog not
quite in step with the others but trying
no everyone's out of step with a dog
oh there you go let's uh soak up some of
the atmosphere on the mall as we enjoy
the band's marching past
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
e
[Music]
okay
[Music]
foreign
the queen became a patron of the dog's
Trust
as a nation of dog lovers to have the
head of state to possibly the most
famous dog owner of the world as a
patron of the UK's largest dog welfare
charity uh was seen seemingly very
fitting I'm joined now by the Charities
chief executive Owen sharp and also
alongside Owen I have Dame Louise Martin
president of the Commonwealth Games at
Federation
hello to you both
um
now I mean talk to me about the Queen's
involvement in the dog's trust because
she is a patron of hundreds of Charities
and how special is it to have her
involvement and what does her
involvement mean it means a huge amount
I mean probably the nation's most famous
dog lover so it's the reservation's
biggest dog charity it's fantastic to
have her involved she's opened many of
her centers over the years but it's just
the general passion that she shows for
dogs that's actually really important
for us because we're all about promoting
good dog welfare and the importance that
dogs play in our life and I think her
majesty is a fantastic example of that
yeah she retired a number of Patriots
a number of years ago she retained her
patronage of the dog's trust which
signifies a very special bond between
you and the queen I think so and we were
we were very touched that she decided to
stay with us
um it was you know it it's really
important clearly her love of dogs is is
something that we all know very famous
for corgis we don't get many corgis in
our re-homing centers it's more mixed
breeds and staffies but we love all dogs
and the queen I think does too yeah
Laura bundock I correspondent was down
on the mile earlier on this morning and
people have brought along their own
corgis yes real corgis and stuff I think
you'd get from the gift shop along here
very popular selling item I would
imagine and
Louise talk to me about Birmingham 2022
happening in a very significant year for
the queen and it underlines her
relationship her strong bond with
Commonwealth Nations it does when you
think that um uh 60 days Time games will
be starting and hopefully her majesty
will be able to offer them but we'll
wait and see what happens but when I
think that it's only six months ago we
were actually handing the bathroom over
to her majesty in Buckingham Palace to
put the message in to send it around the
Commonwealth to make sure that all the
athletes knew that they were going to
come in to Birmingham so it's
birmingham's really getting very
exciting and the place is really looking
good
and and in terms of
the bat on where is it now because
that's that's a huge operation it's very
symbolic because obviously all of the
Commonwealth wants to be linked together
for these games so it's a big operation
well it's coming in from the Caribbean
today as we've re-routed it to come into
Heathrow to do to have this weekend in
London for the Queen's Jubilee because
we just felt that she's here everybody
is here we might as well have some share
in in the bath as it's going around so
we're arriving today and it's going out
to
um Malta on a Monday night Tuesday
morning after we're finished
and are we ready in Birmingham is
Birmingham ready birmingham's ready yeah
it will be a very um
it would be a very big occasion in the
the Platinum Jubilee calendar event
absolutely we've got
well put it this way we've got very few
tickets left police is sold out and the
athletes are really
in the last rows of training to make
sure that they can qualify and come and
the excitement's building throughout the
Commonwealth for this in the back and
sit really
building that excitement for it too and
the photography coming out of that super
oh it's a very exciting time it's a very
exciting year and a great way to
commemorate the Queen's Platinum Jubilee
at home and Dane Louise Martin thank you
so much for joining us how will you be
continuing the celebrations this weekend
if you don't mind me asking working
working yeah of course
so many people working this weekend you
won't be alone yeah well we've still got
1500 dogs to look after so it doesn't
stop but yes we'll take some time to
celebrate as well in all of our centers
as well as across everything we do yeah
an honorable mention actually to
everybody here's working this bank
holiday weekend it's not a yeah it's not
a full four days off for quite a few
people but a lot of people will be able
to join in the festivities uh find the
magic of TV watch it on Sky News we've
got full coverage of everything that's
happening up and down the country and of
course across the Commonwealth thank you
to you both thank you very much for your
weekend thank you
well we're continuing to watch
um what is going on on horse guards
parade in fact
if you just listen I think there is a
tune you will recognize
[Music]
just
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
we know that that's one of her her
places that she's happiest
um and so I think obviously with the new
photograph that we saw at the queen
that's taking at Windsor her looking
quite relaxed
um
entirely Regal which I think was quite
nice kind of a grandmotherly feel to
that photographer very much so that's
the first time we've heard God Save the
Queen today the first of many occasions
over the weekend I'm sure and ending
Lewis Martin because in the Commonwealth
Games Federation is that she was still
here when that was posted it was quite
emotional and I think it will be an
emotional weekend for a lot of people
around and particularly the older
generation yeah
I can't get away from the fact that for
some there's some younger people
they do have mixed feelings about the
royal family and and I think especially
some of the issues that have happened
with the royal families themselves it
has had a had a knock-on impact on their
reputation
um but I think there are still an
enormous number of people across the
country across the Commonwealth across
the world
I feel like I shouldn't speak over this
Applause
just as you mentioned appreciation
exactly and here obviously appreciating
the amazing military space Corps that
we're going to see there is a huge
amount of respect for her she is truly a
unique figure on the world stage
um and and so for her this is this is a
big weekend yes for her to Mark 70 years
on this road the first British wanted to
do so
um but also for her bring the community
together and uh and speak about other
people's sense of service and Duty which
I think is really important for
which is coming up to half past ten
Rihanna remind us where we are in terms
of the schedule for today so at the
moment we are seeing all of the military
gathering at their various different
Master points uh and they will
eventually all As We Know set off down
the mall accompanying various members of
the royal family so what we are what we
have been seeing is cars going into
Buckingham Palace with various members
of the family inside where they will get
into carriages and then they will
process down the mouth of course at
about 11 o'clock the focus will then be
on horse guards parade where we will see
other members of the family and I think
that has of course been another big
talking point is who exactly are we
going to see gathering for this occasion
we know that the queen has already said
that it's only working Royals who will
join her on the balcony but we do now
know that the Duke and Duchess of Sussex
are going to be on the parade ground for
the first time in two years gathering
with other members of the royal family
since they decided to step away from raw
life so that's going to be quite a
moment seeing them on the balcony just
outside the major General's office so
basically we are in that that waiting
stage at the moment the anticipation is
building uh waiting for for that moment
where we finally see members of the
royal family in this glorious weather
heading down the mountain towards horse
guards parade
for the crowd assembled here it is the
show before the show yes
Alistair Bruce our Royal commentator is
uh standing by to
talk through proceedings as and when
they happen he's left us here in the
studio to go and get ready for that
Alistair Bruce frontal knowledge when it
comes to All Things Royal comp and
ceremony very much looking forward to
hearing his commentary as and when that
happens and Brianna talk to me about the
crowd assembled here today because it is
a ticketed event and
now you've caught me out with that one
I'm not entirely sure but I suspect
it is probably people from nominated
Charities nominated Charities you'd
anticipate yeah and also the the greater
the good I suppose yeah former military
personnel I I've been hearing as well
sitting here very patiently uh in the
sunshine to watch what is going on can
we then talk through the latter part of
the day because we're trooping the color
all eyes then will be on the Royal
balcony behind us as you mentioned it
was getting a quick Hoover earlier on
getting ready and then there is an aria
fly past a huge spectacle that's always
so special when that happens
I've spoken to um a former Chief of the
defense staff who on a couple of
occasions has talked about how the queen
found it quite amusing that they were
watching One fly past and the weather
was terrible and you couldn't really see
anything and then they they got together
again for another fly pass and she sort
of Lent over and said well hopefully
we'll be able to see them a bit better
this time
um today it's the perfect perfect
weather for it and um and it I think it
always gives us some of the the nicest
photographs really members of the royal
family because despite the fact that
year in year eight year out they they
see this spectacle pageantry
they all seem to like to fly past and
especially the little ones so the
children see the children on the balcony
so I would anticipate because it's
happened in previous years we have seen
the Duke and Duchess of cambridge's
children so Prince George princess
Charlotte and uh Prince Louis and of
course Willie McKay are they want to
keep their children's lives as private
as possible they want to kind of stop
try and stop too much intrusion but I
think they realize that for these big
moments for them it's it's quite a thing
to be involved and you can see that on
their faces as they're watching things
like the fly pasts and and as I
mentioned earlier I think for the queen
as well it's it's a really important
weekend to have her family around her
and and show the world after a difficult
period that they are united that they
are all working together and that
includes all of those in the line of
succession so the Prince of Wales the
Duke of Cambridge and also Little Prince
George Who of course will have a lot of
responsibility on his shoulders in the
future yes I would imagine the children
will not want to miss the fly past some
70 aircraft taking part it's going to be
quite the spectacle of that happening
after one o'clock this afternoon of
course you can see it live here on Sky
News let's just rejoin events at horse
guards parade and listen they know
what's happening
[Music]
when my mic is out can you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh Rihanna we're just watching the final
preparations for trooping the color
again so many people assembled there it
really is a cast of thousands today uh
more cars arriving who have we not seen
arrive yet so in that minibus I would
anticipate that um and this is purely
guesswork because we can't see the
windows but I suspect it's likely to be
people like the Duke and Duchess of
Gloucester uh the Duke and Duchess of
Kent and
um and potentially some of the Queen's
grandchildren so Zara Tindall and her
family and Peter Phillips and his family
um they of course will not be traveling
in carriages so it is guesswork but in
the past for example for Prince Phillips
Memorial we saw a number of them arrive
um in in a minibus but it's going to be
interesting as well to see we were
talking about Prince George princess
Charlotte and Prince Louis and of course
the queen has many more
great-grandchildren and so it'd be
interesting to see whether or not we see
any of Zara's children for example or
Peter's children and also of course the
big talking point this weekend is the
fact that yes Harry and Megan are over
but they've also we understand brought
with them their children Archie and
lillibet so the Queen's namesake and no
members of royal family have met a
little bit before so it's going to be
interesting across those few days to
find out when exactly we see Harry and
Megan's children and lilybeck turns one
over the course of this yes on Saturday
so it's a big weekend for them and I
think
of course they have become a quite
controversial couple in this country we
can't get away from that
um but I think it's worth saying that
Harry and Megan have consistently talked
about their love and respect for the
queen and the queen has constantly
talked about them as much loved members
of the family and yes we have all the
official Pomp pageantry and the
ceremonial but at the center of this is
a family and a family who like us want
to celebrate what is an incredible
achievement for the matriarch of that
family and so it's only right that they
are with her in the past Prince Edward
her son said to me that they are always
The Supporting Cast and that's exactly
what they'll be again today as we now
know that we are going to see the star
of proceedings on three separate
occasions
behind the scenes Rhiannon
what happens in terms of it's very much
a family affair and we will see them at
certain points over the weekend as
you've outlined but once they leave that
balcony today is there a family party
behind the scenes they have they
normally have a bit of a lunch at
Buckingham Palace and then of course we
know that the queen tonight uh is going
to be involved in the beacon lighting
ceremony so around half past night so
she will eventually head back to Windsor
I think they do see it as a family
get-together yes for some of it we're
all watching for example when they're
all out there on the major generals
balcony the body language experts are
going to have an absolute field day
because they always do so I think for
the family of course it's important to
have that time where they can they could
get together behind the scenes and catch
up because don't forget they are all
incredibly busy for example William and
Kate recently jetting off to the
Caribbean Prince Charles and Camilla
going to Canada traveling this weekend
around the UK yeah and that's a really
important point to make I think as all
of our eyes at the moment are trained on
London understandably because this is
where there has been this enormous build
up
um the cheers are for somebody bringing
some water to the uh to the crowds it is
very hot here today better than it
raining
um I think that all eyes at the moment
of course on Central London but but for
the royal family this is about the
entire United Kingdom coming together
and elements of the Commonwealth as well
so we know that the Duke and Duchess of
Cambridge are going to be going to Wales
we know that the Princess Royal is off
to Edinburgh and also the early castle
of Wessex they're going to go to
Northern Ireland so making sure that
every part of the Queen's United Kingdom
feels that they they are in Subway
a busy weekend they really aren't
working Royals this weekend let's bring
in Aleister Bruce we're watching scenes
live at Force guards parade the final
elements being put in place for trooping
the color Alistair
Sarah Jane thank you very much indeed
and to everybody Welcome to horse guards
here at the heart of London
all six guards have now formed their
line it's like an L across two sides of
the square
and all are taking their place before
the officers fall in
in the background in this gorgeous day
with the sun and occasional clouds
giving some respite to those on Parade
we see
the ability building
and in the distance
Lord Nelson on top of his column
and this is
a queen's birthday parade for trooping
the color of the first Battalion Irish
guards
they were formed as a regiment by Queen
Victoria in 1900.
and since their formation this is the
13th time
they have trooped their color
for The Sovereign on the sovereign's
birthday parade
there is the color of the first
battalion
it has the Queen's Cipher of e2r at the
center and signed by a royal crown and
it's encircled by the collar of the
order of sympatrick which was the order
created to Mark service
in Ireland
many years ago and its motto is quiz
separabid
he whom separates which is the motto the
Irish guards
the commanding officer of the parade
the field officer in Brigade waiting
we'll take command
and he will fall in his officers in due
course
and they will March out to their six
guards there are three officers for each
guard
and on parade today of the six guards to
the left of our picture is the escort
for the color formed by the Irish guards
of course
then two and three guards also formed by
the first Battalion Irish guards
number four guard is formed by nine
Megan company of the Grenadier guards
number five by F company Scots guards
number six
is formed by number seven company called
stream guards
you can hear helicopters overhead there
was a small incident as the soldiers
marched towards horse guards earlier
today
and the sensitivities in modern day of
security
always
the bottom of the picture there the end
sign who will be carrying the color
later on
it's a big day for him
second Lieutenant Charles battle
who will be trooping
his battalion's color before the
sovereign's representative the Prince of
Wales
the field officer in Brigade waiting
today
September James Aldridge who's currently
at the commanding officer of the Irish
guards you can tell the Irish guards
their buttons are in fours
and they have
Patrick's blue plume in the right hand
side
of their best skin caps
they're now going to fix bayonets
that's the instruction to grab hold of
the bayonet at the rear of the belt
[Music]
now to place the bayonets on the top of
the sa80 rifle and a reminder that all
these soldiers on parade today
are trained as soldiers to deliver
calculated precise and legal violence
and protection of the nation and its
values anywhere in the world
shortly an instruction will be given to
open up number three guard in order that
the Royal procession coming from
Buckingham Palace with with carriages
can make its way through
two horse cars so they can watch the
parade
[Music]
it's a reminder that most of these
maneuvers
from the days of the Napoleonic Wars in
fact the first birthday parade took
place
the King's Birthday it was King George
III
in 1805 shortly before
the Battle of Trafalgar on the 21st of
October later that year
and they've cleared that opening so that
when the carriages come and passed the
great guards Memorial which you see
there with the
five bronze
soldiers of the five guards regiments in
front of Portland Marvel still Hawk
marked
with
the detritus of the bombs that landed on
London during the Blitz
[Music]
for all those gathered here there's a
sense of anticipation and a reminder
that this is the highest tribute that
the Armed Forces through the Queen's
household division can pay to the queen
to Mark her
official birthday her actual birthday
was on the 21st of April
and this event is to try and make sure
that the event takes place in better
weather
across the guards Memorial we see horse
guards building
was designed by Adam a complete
complete knock on after his death to
go in line with the designs around the
rest of those guys
[Music]
and it was here that in Queen Elizabeth
the first day there used to be
tournaments where Knights would test
their military capabilities and I can
hear the clamor for the carriages as
they come down the Mal
TS approach Road
[Music]
Scotts we'll see them shortly in the
trees coming down from the top there as
we hear the bands leaving Buckingham
Palace with the Royal Colonels who will
be representing the queen later at this
parade
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
will come to collect that color
and then troop it through all six guards
the ceremony used to be called the
lodging of the colors which in a way
makes it easier to understand because it
was important for soldiers here to
identify know where it
if they're a good view of horse guards
building with the balconies dressed or
where the royal family will watch this
event
[Applause]
we're hearing the reactions down the
mall
as the carriages make their way to horse
guards now
field of stream Brigade waiting has
moved to position beside the opening in
number three guard in order to give a
royal salute to members of the royal
family when they arrive
it's perhaps worth thinking what it must
feel like to be a young Guardsman on
parade today
they've been training along with the
king's troop Royal Horse artillery
since March for this event
they've been sighted at and drilled by
drill sergeants
in order to achieve the highest possible
standards and the mass bands of the
household Division II under their drum
majors
have been preparing the music
for this event
just seeing the controller the Lord
Chamberlain's office just walking along
the back there with some Grooms from the
Royal Muse
to be in position before the arrival of
the carriages
and I can hear them now and see the
outriders the riding Grooms today
[Music]
Nicholas
Celestron on horses sergeant major and
Bermuda and they're leading the first
carriage
the number one Baruch in which the
Duchess of Cornwall and The Duchess of
Cambridge are traveling
yesterday The Duchess of Cornwall was
invested with the insignia
of Lady of the most noble order of the
Garter by her majesty the queen
she was appointed to the order of the
Gaza recently and later this year
Queen will become the person who has
held the Garter longer than anybody else
in history
she was made
a lady of the Gospel by her father
oh
[Music]
the three children the Duke and Duchess
of Cambridge
traveling with their mother
and with the Duchess of course
and in the second carriage
the Allen counts of Wessex for their two
children
and I kind of Southern
and in the Balmoral vandal
that you can dash of cluster and buy
servants are Tim Lawrence
for his wife a princess Royal as Carmel
losing Royals
is gold sticking waiting today
responsible
protection of demonic getting back
to the 1600s
they will Dismount under the arch
and go up to the major General's office
where other members of the royal family
will be waiting
and number three guard will now close up
again in very much
a reminder as I was saying
of the Napoleonic Wars
and the troll movements that were so
vital in creating
the squares that defeated
Napoleon at that battle
down the mall now will be coming
the Prince of Wales who represents Her
Majesty the queen
the Duke of Cambridge his Colonel of the
Irish guards and
Princess Royal
I was mentioned
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the Prime Minister watching with his
wife from the stands
as we see the procession beginning
and right at the front we have
four Troopers of the lifeguards
who are following the Brigade major
today
the lieutenant colonel James Shaw
or Troopers
who were judged to be the best in
turnout at the princess Elizabeth cup
competition
our Troopers
Samuel Wallace
to Vita Milton Carver
Anna said Yusuf Hassan
and behind you can hear the wonderful
sound of the mounted band of the
household Cavalry at the two drum horses
named Harry and Ed
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
will now take their place underneath the
cover and canopy of the trees
a reminder that for the Queens
Platinum Jubilee
a canopy of trees has been the Queen's
wish across the Commonwealth
and today I think some of
the horses of the household cavalry
will be glad of the cover they receive
from those trees and behind
the band comes the first and second
division of the sovereigns escort
formed by the lifeguards
now we can just see beyond them the
Royal kernels
and if her majesty The Queen Is Watching
she will be
sharp eyed on all those horses she
can read
every one of those animals with an
expert's High
foreign
there are 118 horses forming part of the
sovereigns
escort both first second and also the
third and fourth
divisions
and the standard of the
lifeguards which will be taken past the
Prince of Wales later today
his Royal Highness the Prince of Wales
trust and the uniform
of Colonel
of the wild scars and wearing the green
sash of the order of the thistle
and the color which is like a chain over
his shoulders of the order of the Garter
followed by
the Duke of Cambridge download the Irish
guards and the Princess Royal they will
salute the color
as they pass
in respect
of its importance
it represents
The Sovereign it represents the heart
and soul of the Irish gods
and it is
an object that has been consecrated
in a church service
because it embodies all the past and the
presence
the impressionist of the Royal Hospital
Chelsea standing there in their long
coats representing centuries of service
to a queen who is platinum Jubilee is
today and at exactly 11 o'clock
the Prince of Wales will stand beneath
horse guards Arch and receive
the full salute which is for his mother
the queen on her Platinum Jubilee
and all efforts are made that the Royal
procession will be in position precisely
at 11 o'clock
all right
Royal Sonic
region
of
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
well a very happy birthday to the queen
wherever she's watching and up in the
balcony Prince George looks down on his
grandfather and father as they now start
the inspection
and for every Soldier who's been
rehearsing and preparing for this event
the sharp eye or
first of all the Brigade major who has
been
probably ice hard in trying to make sure
everyone has done their best
we will be keeping his eye to make sure
that all the work is perfect but the
eyes that matter today are those of the
royal Colonels
first of all to
the escort for the color who are waiting
now and ultimately as I was saying
they will become the guard at Buckingham
Palace at the end of the day
foreign
music is Ladysmith composed of specific
specifically for this parade and
it commemorates the town of Ladysmith
which is where so many Irish regiments
were incredibly Brave during what was
called the boa War
between Victoria
of course before
Charlotte
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this year commemorates the Centenary of
that historic moment
in 1922
Prince Wales inspecting the
divisions of
[Music]
sovereign's left hand is the gold stick
which she carries as gold stick him
waiting
world of sea and the other cuddle of the
lifeguards is
General Sir Edward Smith Osborne they
take it in turns
[Music]
the inspecting officers will now return
to
guards Arch and prepare for the slow
troop by the mass bands
[Applause]
and while immense relief for all the
soldiers taking part as they change arms
and place the sa80 rifle which they use
in battle
on the other shoulder and into their
arms
these soldiers have been in uniform
since quite early this morning and it's
a very long parade
and they'll be longing to start marching
later on in both the slow
and quick March past but first of all
our eyes go to the mass bands of the
house
[Music]
of Cambridge looking on it's a perfect
Vantage there
[Music]
royal family have a television in the
room too because they can't all see this
Parade from the window
and
the traditional music for the slow Troop
is Lei Hugo
and it's a reminder of how important
music has always been
to soldiers on the battlefield
word of command to troop we'll be given
and the mass bands will respond
s
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
greatly
[Music]
okay
behind us at Earth stop oh what
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
under the direction of the direct drum
Majors from Majors
Chambers Fitzgerald Valley
slow troop comes to an end
and with his mace you'll see this
brought to a finale
[Music]
and now we go into the quick true room
I I spoke to Lieutenant Colonel Simon
hall yesterday evening and he said this
is his favorite bit of music the
Platinum Jubilee
[Music]
especially opposed for today and for the
queen it starts with a Melody based
around let Aaron remember freshman can
slow March in the Irish bars and
it was composed by Sergeant Shelton
and he's playing the French horn in the
middle there somewhere with the mix
meanwhile he'll see peeling off on his
own
alone drummer
young Theo Knox who's 18 years old from
the Irish guards and he will take
position at the end of the line in order
to give signal or
ago and collect the color or trooping
[Music]
the rear of those Mass bands of the
Pipers soon we'll hear them as they fill
the traditional
Melodies From
the pateras on our way
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Ox has given the command and the captain
of the escort hands over to the
suppleton and the subtleton today who's
Captain Freddie Bradshaw will now go
with the end sign second Lieutenant
Charles battle and the escort for the
color to collect
the color that's waiting to the right of
our screen and you'll wonder what on
Earth is the band going to do well they
will get out of the way and reposition
themselves
[Music]
a score for the color in close order
left yes
so being given left dress is an
instruction for all of them to look over
to their left shoulder to make sure that
they're all in a straight line it's a
challenge and part of the Excellence of
drill to train soldiers to work together
in order to be absolutely ready for
battle and at the back there you see
regimental assault major
warned officer first class David Griffis
has handed over his pay stick to
Guardsman Kevin Newell who takes it away
because this is the only occasion that a
regimental warrant officer
[Music]
to the traditional tune the British
grenadiers of the escort for the color
moves forward
and it will turn to face directly the
color that it has the privilege of both
guarding and trooping later on meanwhile
the mass bands do the spin wheel what
are the most extraordinary movements on
Parade every single soldier has a
different set of instructions in order
to adjust the band's positioned by 90
degrees we still have it in the right
position to lead the rest of the parade
and although it looks like they'll bump
into each other they just don't
[Music]
thank you
and you might have heard that the
longest officer sat it right sir on the
left-hand side there to give the
subtleton clarity that he can March
forward meanwhile at the back of the
escort for the color is the end sign
back
of the
Silverton and waiting now in position
and at the back of the escort the
regiment assault measure will March off
when he's ready and signed with him to
collect the color
lieutenant colonel
director of music and commanding officer
of the mass bands
positioned to
lead the national anthem
[Applause]
[Music]
and the whole parade ground is prepared
for the moment when the escort becomes
the escort to the color when they will
give their highest salute to the color
oh
thank you
on the same position the original move
off
poor regimental sergeant major David
Griffiths of the Irish guards nothing
could be more uplifting than to come and
collect its regiments color which was
given to the Irish guards on May the
17th by the Duke of Cambridge at Windsor
Castle he picks up
the unsign who follows
we got to the color Sergeant
after saluting the regimental measure
will take hold of the color
and turn and present it to the enzyme
the second Lieutenant Charles battle
when he was chosen to do this role just
before Saint Patrick's Day
earlier this year
must have given
a huge sense of anticipation to get this
moment right you will complete his
salute and place his sword back in his
cupboard
tricky maneuver
when he certainly simply throw it away
and grab the cover
when he turns
the escort for the club comes escort to
the color and
honors
[Music]
escort to the color slow up
and sign will take his position the
regimental major having completed his
task
will prepare for the troop
and under the Sultan's command
the escort to the color will now
troop the color all through
the other five guards
escort to the color
change arms
it'll be getting warmer for the soldiers
enter
oh launch
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
it's perhaps worth bearing in mind that
yesterday evening I was on the mall and
I saw most of the musicians of the mass
bands
preparing to rehearse on the stages
underneath Buckingham Palace for
Sunday's Platinum Jubilee pageant so
those musicians have had very little
rest and they have much to do
this weekend but today giving music for
this moment of the actual trooping and
for each of the soldiers here to look at
that color identify it and know where
it's kept the music will
develop into the
Grenadier slow March
as they start to pass through each of
the guards
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
second Lieutenant Charles battle and
sign today who will become end sign of
the guard at the end of this parade so
it's 24 hours on guard commanding the
troops guarding Saint James's Palace
later on
24 years old born and all the shot
he committed the army
April 2021
after this he was at Newcastle
University carrying
carrying the Queen's color
newly made
presented
earlier this year
they will take their position
at the right of the line again when the
subtleton
Freddie Bradshaw who has been commanding
the escort to the color
and that command to the captain of the
escort an age of Charlie Allman Brown
let's go
[Music]
oh
yeah John
escort circular change and
get that rifles in the position said
that they can present arms
[Music]
whoa
oh
officers
take post
so the officers who
will now need to be in position for
the March passed in slow and quick time
take their places
ready for that and the color is passed
to the back where it will be protected
most
and it's surrounded by its escort
and we will see the configuration of the
parade altered by the field officer and
Brigade waiting
[Music]
and form
marching
formation
alcohol
right form
works
[Music]
and this music played by the core drums
the girl I left behind me an English
Folk Song dating back to the Elizabethan
era that's the last Elizabethan era
said to have been played when soldiers
left for war
even on a naval vessel as it set sail
and it was first printed with text
in Dublin in 1791
[Music]
good to hear the core drums for they
form the oldest form of Music known on
the battlefield
they will now be Advanced the whole turn
around look straight at us
turn
number six gone
close order March
[Music]
move to the right in threes
form threes
right
Gods will March passed in slow and quick
time
by the left
low March
[Music]
enormous relief for all those Guardsmen
taking part the chance to get moving
again after a long stand
and this March past in slow time
it's a chance for them to show the
Excellence of their drill the holding of
their formations
and a reminder to all of us that the
effort they put in on the drill Square
is useful in battle to make sure that
all these soldiers work as a team
together
and perhaps
the most extreme of human challenges
[Music]
is where every single Guardsman
non-commissioned officer has to work
with concentration as you'll see them
come into position
under slow march today is Bob's own
arranged by Sergeant Barrett
it commemorates Field Marshal Lord
Frederick Roberts who won the Victoria
Cross who came from County Waterford in
Ireland
first Colonel of the Irish guards
was born in India
anglo-ara's family
and he served as a young officer in
what has been called the Indian Mutiny
is often known
as the first Indian War of Independence
where he won his Victoria Cross
but as a field Marshal
he was a great emblem to
build a tree for it's prowess
and he's always been quite a figurehead
for the Irish guards whose day it is
today
[Music]
son of the escort to the color move
forwards
to be at the front of the escort in
order for him to lower the color of the
first Battalion Irish guards in salute
to her majesty the queen on her Platinum
Jubilee
Lucy isn't here there isn't a soldier on
this parade Square who doesn't want to
Mark and wish the queen well for it is
in her name that they serve and if
called to do so go to battle
Place their lives on the line
[Music]
watching from the balcony we saw the
Duchess of Cambridge who on St Patrick's
Day this year
presented Shamrock to every one of these
Irish Guardsmen
escort and to Garden three guard
in salute we move to the slowmart of the
Irish guards let Aaron remember and the
color will be lowered
foreign
[Applause]
number two guard Irish guards giving
their salute to the books of Wales
followed by
another three guard meanwhile the escort
to the color has recovered working eyes
front
you'll notice the commander of number
two guard wears a Welsh guards plume of
white and green here's
probably the only whilst Guardsman on
parade today otherwise all
the other five regiments are well
represented
as nightmaker company of the grenadiers
passes Scipio
it was a great Opera for which this
music plays such a significant part
and the Queen
became kernel of the grenadiers 80 years
ago this year
my old red hunt represented today by F
company Scots guards the music that the
barbable goal
later today the colonel of the Scots
guards the Duke of Kent will be with the
queen when she appears on the balcony
and finally Figaro by Mozart for slow
March 4-7 company can't stream guards
foreign
which comes from a comic Opera Written
In 1902 about the tough life that people
had in the court of Queen Elizabeth the
first
rather suitably it's called Long Live
Elizabeth
foreign
having received permission from The
Prince of Wales the field of stream
Brigade waiting
now it moves into position to break them
into Quick time they'll then be
four drum beats with voice site's quick
March and they'll swing their arms and
come round
again in QuickTime
[Music]
leading the parade at the moment is the
major of the parade major Adrian have a
look at the Scots guards
he's currently serving with the Cold
Stream Gods as indeed now members of the
House of the mission moved from
Battalion to Battalion
for their careers and for effect
foreign
[Music]
gives the command that all these
soldiers want which is to march in
QuickTime swinging their arms
and I always think marching that little
bit taller this time the color will
remain at the rear as they March fast
meanwhile the Pipers moved to a
different position with the mass bands
so that their music can be heard
properly later on
[Music]
now these Corners are terribly
complicated as I was saying everybody's
shouting to each other there's lots of
Rights left left a bit sir as the
soldiers communicate with their officers
who are out in front and can't see
whether they're in the middle or not but
everyone you'll see with their eyes
darting left and right
foreign
the last of the soldiers coming into
line is in position he'll give
let's come on to the words and right sir
there you are and off they go
and the next lot moving
it's very complicated and they have been
for some time
[Music]
foreign
of the line composed by Major George
Wilcox
it's
one of his many
positions
it's one that we have major general
commanding the house television
particularly wanted
that's General Chris ginka is
responsible to the queen former
preparation and Leadership of her
household troops he has delivered two
troopings at Windsor Castle under the
extraordinary circumstances presented to
the Army by covid not only were they
preparing for the parade but they were
also delivering support to the NHS up
and down the country as many of the
Armed Forces did
but today the household division have
demonstrated that they are the best at
troll
foreign
takes place for the Irish guards listen
to St Patrick's Day and the pipes
[Music]
and the music will now break into the
Grandeur guards quick March which is the
British grenadiers
foreign
[Music]
to that tune and all the soldiers March
that a little bit taller
and the Cold Stream guards quick march
by Val ham
and plus seven company called stream
guards
a chance to make their second salute to
the Queen's representative
[Music]
and into the last of the quick marches
slattery's mounted but it's French
written in 1889 by the 19th century
Irish musician composer Percy French
[Music]
song with lyrics
it's a personal favorite of Queen
Elizabeth the queen mother who always
used to present Shamrock to the Irish
guards
foreign
the
L shape that they had at the start of
the parade and it's an impressive sight
to see
these five guards advancing towards us
now
and they get the instruction to form the
line
it's another one of those
field Maneuvers
that must have passed a certain amount
of fear in those who face them in the
19th century
foreign
[Music]
I don't know
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
tight post
quick Moss
the officers now move again to their
positions at the front of their troops
and sign
coming through the escort to the color
once again giving always the color
the greatest care ambassy in open order
left and right
Drax
so dressing again and they'll all look
as they should to get in position
reform the straight lines that have been
lost during that marching
almost entertaining to see them
shuffling in different positions
Meanwhile we're here
they're marching away from the solution
base to a tune with the pipes and drums
Field Marshal Alexander of Tunis another
great Irish guardsman
he was
regimental kernel for a Time
but came to prominence as one of the
significant Army commanders of the
second World War
[Music]
the purpose is to get the mass bands of
the house subdivision out of the way
in order for the
United band of the household coverage
come forward
[Music]
oh tight
[ __ ] covers
[Music]
under its director of music
manager Paul Collis Smith
with the two drum horses
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
will come the king's troop Royal Horse
artillery
the guns that will fire an 82 gun salute
later this morning
a few minutes till one o'clock
the king's troop Royal Horse artillery
who used to be called the riding Troop
until King George VI visited them once
crossed out the word riding
and wrote in Kings
and when the queen came to the throne 70
years ago
she wanted it to remain
King's troop in recognition of her
father
and the 13 pounder guns the first of
which represent the colors equivalent
for the
Royal Horse artillery
[Music]
commanding officer nature Fran Sykes
leads her troops
with her Trumpeter followed by her other
section commanders and their trumpeters
and
the Royal artillery slow March
[Applause]
[Music]
these guns saw active service in the
first World War
and with the gun and limber
away
1.5 tons
and when they're
making their Journey with the horses
they're 54 feet from we're going to end
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and you'll notice that A and B section
at the front carrying the guns that are
saluted are much lighter
[Music]
than enf subsections at the back who
have the darker horses
[Music]
and the lifeguards now come past
with their regimental walk
also called the lifeguards and they
lower their standard in salute to the
Queen's representative
[Music]
standard Bearer today is warrant officer
second class
Christopher lybird
[Music]
seeing the farriers at the back there
one officer second class Paul James who
was injured by an IED in
2009 while the blues and Royals
March past
[Music]
the regimental March was arranged by
Major Ted jeans on the amalgamation in
1969.
combining two slow marches from before
and the March is thought to have been
composed for Queen Victoria's mother The
Duchess of Kent
seeing the Duchess of Gloucester and the
right hand window and
[Music]
Cambridge children in the left with
their cousins
[Music]
hahaha
the trumpet gives instruction for the
trot
the field officers will jump into that
Trooper uh Matilda Bishop giving that
instruction and the noise of the horses
and the guns as they come past you can
only imagine it let's enjoy it as they
March past at the trot
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
horses lost six Rider
it's always a concern for those taking
part and
very quickly
as some gabri will do their best to
recover that horse but horses tend to
Apollo their friends no matter what
you
pause
I'm sure that that also will be
recovered
[Music]
Cavalry
saluted the Prince of Wales
we're trying to get hold of that horse I
think
[Music]
King's troop Royal Horse artillery
leaving the parade up there going down
horse guards approach Freight and
they'll be moving down the mall shortly
to Green Park in order to fire an 82 gun
salute to Mark the sovereigns
official birthday and uh Platinum
Jubilee yeah and also
the anniversary of her coronation
69 years ago today as the
band of the household covering gives us
salute to the Prince of Wales as they
take leave
of all scars
the
sovereign
[Music]
also position themselves for their task
[Music]
so with the color trooped the March
passed in slow and quick time for the
six guards and the walk and trot pass
for the
King's troop and the household Cavalry
complete
the field officer in Brigade waiting
sits on his horse at the center of this
parade ground
will prepare
for the return
to Buckingham Palace
but of course put the escort to the
color
their task is only just beginning
because they will form
response from the crowd
thank you
[Applause]
my name is the royal family will leave
the center room in order to travel
two bucking reps the Royal salute to the
Queen's representative
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
part of the royal salute
to Mark the final part of this birthday
present to her majesty the queen
and the field officer prepares his
troops
there's a small weight here while
members of the Royal Family Leave horse
guards and pass up to
Trafalgar Square by way of Whitehall and
down the mall and they need to get ahead
of this procession
before
the household Cavalry and the guards
March back to Buckingham Palace but we
know waiting at Buckingham Palace will
be the queen ready to receive
her own personal salute from all her
troops
in a way it gives to these troops who
are being
thanks for their work here
after walking around
earlier today
there's a tremendous atmosphere out
there wishing good world to the queen
formation
in 1913 King George V created a new
development to enable him as king to
lead all his troops away from
and that tradition has been carried on
by Edward VII King George VI and Queen
Elizabeth II and today on Her Majesty's
the Prince of Wales the senior colonel
we'll lead the Queen's troops back to
Buckingham Palace to give the Sovereign
their salute
[Music]
divisions
about
turn
we can hear a roar down the mouth
as everyone sees the foreign
foreign
artillery out the front
and all of them receiving
a wonderful cheer
[Music]
it's been a very long day for the king's
troop they
were exercising their horses around the
circuit here Birdcage Walk and horse
guards which hugely stirred up the
crowds on the Mull
and they're still very full of life
and behind the king's troop Royal Horse
artillery who are going
to Green Park in order to position their
guns ready for the gun salute which will
start at 12 52.
and must be finished by 12 59.
after firing
82 guns
London couldn't be looking better today
over the Queen Victoria Memorial
it was for this Memorial that the great
processional route with its special
tarmac which has
special oxide dye in it to make it look
like a red carpet all the way from
admiralty arch up to the Palace it had
always been an area where people
played a game called pelmel in the time
of King Charles II
now organized into
a processional route which probably
knows no equal in the world
car coming down brings them to the Royal
household
or the return of the Royal Family
and the Royal Standard is flying above
Buckingham Palace which means Her
Majesty has arrived from Windsor Castle
the state standard is
32 feet long
the lives of England
and
the lion of Scotland and the harp
the field officer Brigade waiting will
now ask the Prince of Wales for
permission to March
shoots back to Buckingham Palace
but they will wait
until the Garrison sergeant major said
all is clear
ly
[Music]
costume guards
the regimental Lieutenant Khan with
Grenadier cards and the kernel
of the lifeguards
[Applause]
and with the outriders from the Royal
Muse
The Duchess of Cornwall with the Duchess
of Cambridge and their three children
followed by the island countries of
Wessex and their two children
then finally by the Duke and Duchess of
Gloucester
and Admiral said Timothy Lawrence
saying that yesterday the queen invested
The Duchess of Cornwall
as a lady of the order of the garter
[Applause]
and the George Louis in Charlotte
quite an experience
done them all together for the first
time
as the streetliners present arms
and marching off to Irish saffron which
is the color of the Kilts worn by
the Pipers in the Irish Gods lovely
saffron
[Music]
Ranger Sergeant Adam
started his military training in 2002 he
was a saxophonist in the hazards and
light dragoons served in Falklands
Brunei Canada Cyprus just reminds you
that all these troops be they musician
or
Soldier Trooper whatever
they're all ready to
do the bidding
of the nation and go to war
here the Prince of Wales with
sister the Princess Royal and the Duke
of Cambridge who's regiment the Irish
guards have now trooped their color
escorted by the field officer in Brigade
waiting make their way down to
Buckingham Palace where we know the
queen is waiting
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
Victoria Memorial
shortly the
Carriage procession
and it really is an enormous Royal
Standard and today it only comes out for
trooping the color
it lollaps in the Wind
all right strong canopy in those trees
but for those of us who broadcast
quite a lot of pulling around too and
there's been quite a bit of sneezing and
coughing
I expect the crowd of Felton today
and through these great Gates which
start out onto the mall
South Africa and West Africa marked in
those two
Great Gate posts into the mall
Queen Victoria Memorial itself
full of emblem B
Lew Wessex is wearing the uniform of the
London guards
newly formed out of the reserve units of
London London Scottish the London Irish
company of the rifles
and also part of the Princess of Wales
Royal regiment
now fully parts
of the guards division
everyone stands for members of the world
families they come back to Buckingham
Palace
Palace and their intent will be to try
and get into position so that they can
see the troops return
and in time for that return her majesty
the queen will come out onto the balcony
and she will be accompanied by
done with the Scots guards
Kent
was her first cousin
his father was killed during the second
World War
when his airplane crashed into Hills in
bad weather
in the north of Scotland
the Queen's Reign really has spanned
quite a period of time
and she's seen many of these parades but
she first came onto parade as Colonel
of the Grenadier guards an appointment
she was given by the king in 1942
80 years ago this year
King George V planned it
[Music]
descendant Prince of Wales representing
the queen leads the troops to their
duties
[Music]
thank you
and
Prince Wales Princess Royal and the Duke
of Cambridge all wearing the green sash
of the order of the thistle which is
Scotland's senior order
and because it's a color day they're
wearing those chains of the senior order
the order of the garter
foreign
following up with the plumed hat is the
marsh of the horse Lord demorley
to the Queen's Aquarius
and the other Representatives the
regiments the kind of lifeguards
curl of the upholstering guards and the
regimental cards
it's a great sight to see them coming
home
and trot along behind the Royal Colonels
also with his plumed
cocked hat is the major general command
in the house cell division who must be
immensely proud of all those who he
commands in the household division for
the birthday present they've given the
queen
today
it's taken a lot of planning a lot of
hard work
and getting these troops ready for such
Excellence whilst also training them a
battle
is a tough challenge
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
are really enjoying this they've waited
a long time some of them have been
staying in tents through that awful
weather we had the other day
whether that prevented the Queen's
airplane from Landing when she came back
from Scotland
thunder and lightning was intense over
London
many loyal members of the public were
very flimsy tents along the mall I can
tell you
many of these musicians will be back
on duty for the pageant on Sunday I was
with them when they did their rehearsal
last night
so they didn't get much sleep before the
early start today
they waited so that Diana Ross's
musicians could rehearse before them
because
they had to get away so well done
tell me about the Armed Forces to just
get on with it and
all these musicians have military roles
in time of battle
you get a good chance to see all the
different uniforms you've got the
grenadiers on the left there with their
buttons equally spaced then in the
middle and slip to the right of our
picture we've got the Scots guards with
thistles of their collar and buttons
with trees and the queen has come onto
the balcony we particular Kent
[Applause]
[Applause]
there's quite a lot of stuff in the way
of the balcony of this particular
Platinum Jubilee it will make for the
public it very difficult to see the
balcony and
when One Compares with the coronation
and previous
jubilees there will be a difference this
year and all of that front of the palace
is a building site now
and so they have specially constructed a
safe route for the queen to come from
her rooms
in order to be in position as
the Duke returns a salute to
those passing by
foreign
but the queen won't really see them
because from that balcony the Queen
Victoria Memorial put up
[Music]
and she has the chance to take the
salute from her household cavalry
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
the queen is
colonelin chief of the Minnesota Cavalry
Regiment
made up as we've seen of the lifeguards
and the blues and Royals
lifeguards to the senior regiment in the
British army formed to look after King
Charles II when he was in Exile during
the Commonwealth
from there
see the pipe that's not just blowing a
little bit of air into their pipes to
keep them warm for the moment they need
to
play just to keep the tunes ready
thank you
[Music]
s ah the rear of the parade from the
Irish guards okay long dark green capes
it's a great sight looking all the way
down to admiralty art
a reminder that this is the 40th
anniversary of the Falklands War the
Scots guards and Oscars with the
household covering
particularly the blues and Royals played
their part in the liberation of those
items
that battle was taking place literally
while this parade took place in 1982 and
the queen
stopped the parade and they held asylums
for other members of the household
division at that time fighting for the
liberation of the Falkland Islands
this is after all a military family and
the household division are part of a
wider family the Army which is part of
an even wider family
the Armed Forces
and on behalf of the Armed Forces we'll
see the Royal Air Force fly past at one
o'clock
this is their salute
to the queen on her Platinum Jubilee and
she waits to receive that salute
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and you see the escort to the color
forming
two detachments
ready for this very personal salute
[Music]
that'll be the Buckingham Palace
Detachment Anderson James's Palace
detachment
saying all through this parade it's only
the beginning for the escort to the
color because they form the royal guard
for the next 24 hours
so they have a changing the guard
ceremony to perform once
the queen has received her salute and
the balcony appearance has taken place
[Applause]
and for the other troops it's a return
to barracks
where they will be dismissed and will
head off to enjoy if they're not on duty
over the next few days
the rest of this Platinum Jubilee
weekend like the rest of us
and you see the escort to the color
going to the second entrance to the
Palace in order to start there changing
the guard ceremony and numbers two three
four and five guards
will give an eyes right to the queen as
they head to Wellington barracks
[Music]
and it won't be long now before the
streetliners dismant you can see some of
the half companies already
falling from the sides into the center
in order to March away and then the
Metropolitan Police
will allow the public who are now in the
mall watching to come forward and be in
front of the palace for the one o'clock
appearance by the queen with other
members of royal family who currently
support her in her work as head of state
and there she will
Douglas give a wave and that might be a
reaction from the crowd let's see
[Music]
that's worth bearing in mind the
challenge for the police on days like
this we live in a democracy and everyone
has their opinions and on occasions like
this
is inevitable people want to express
them not everybody is comfortable with
a simple situation but I think those
cheers suggest that quite a lot of
[Applause]
for the queen this is quite a weekend
and she will be starting the Beacon
Lighting
later today
tomorrow she may come to Saint Paul's
Cathedral for a service
where she will
reflect upon
70 years as sovereign
she will also
be keeping close watch of
the results of the derby
on Saturday it should be run on that
sometimes sadly her horses were
withdrawn not that long ago
but I think she has some hopefuls for
Royal Ascot later in the year
he's been winning quite a lot of races
recently
so that gives her great pleasure she
steps away
losing a stick that was given to her as
a present by the army
[Applause]
so that was the Queen's birthday parade
and in every respect
the queen has played her part
and later on she will
come out and receive
a response at her balcony appearance at
one o'clock just after 82 guns will have
been fired by the King Street Royal
Horse artillery
in Green Park and we see later on the
crowds coming down from the malware
they've patiently watched to be part of
this great start
to the Queens Platinum Jubilee year
well that brings to a close the first
stage of these Platinum GB celebrations
the trooping of the color and the queen
in her first balcony appearance of today
we are live here on Sky News at Bucky
and Palace following proceedings all day
and we are joined by a very special
guest it's almost like having royalty
here it is Dame Joanna lovely how lovely
to be I can't tell you how thrilling it
is to be here because to watch it on
television is something but to be here
and actually see the physical thing the
sound of the horses the bands the
glittering and the crowds just thrilled
it's really enchanting yeah it has been
such a special couple of hours Rihanna
let's talk about what we've witnessed
where should we start I think the main
focal point was the carriage procession
with the Royals and we saw the Queen's
youngest great grandchildren we saw for
instance George and Louis and Princess
Charlotte their first Carriage
procession that's right of course this
is a weekend like no other we have never
seen a platinum of Jubilee in this
country before no other Monarch has ever
marked 70 years on the throne and yes
there's the big official pageantry and
spectacle but also I think we were
reminded that the center of this there
is a family who all want to come
together to celebrate this amazing
milestone for their mother their
grandmother and their great-grandmother
and so I think that is why Prince
William and Kate decided that today was
the right moment when Prince George
Prince Louis and Princess Charlotte
should all have their moment in a
carriage and we saw them riding past and
have to say Prince George slightly
tentative about his waving but Louie and
Charlotte definitely giving it a good go
and um and yeah will you and Kate
and we can show you the pictures now and
they were in a carriage with the Duchess
of Cornwall as well and yeah there you
go princess Charlotte she's a little
star in the making I think the hair wave
is spot on Joanna what struck you about
what we've watched unfold over the last
hour or so it's the usual thing I mean
it's just extraordinary to see a British
ceremony at its very very best and being
the daughter of a soldier I'm always
terribly proud to see the military out
absolutely can you think how hard it is
to ride a horse and play a musical
instrument and stay in line here and
follow orders I can't do any of those
let alone all of them together it's like
you know it's like one of those it's
just Sensational and there's such a huge
Buzz of affection from everybody here
when every time the the um the you know
God Save the Queen has played everybody
stands up everybody's creating their
necks hoping to see them and then to see
them literally marching past here that's
wonderful and here's this lovely look at
that
and even though all the costumes are
kind of sent set from another Century we
almost don't want them ever to change we
don't want to see them in t-shirts and
jeans
full ceremonial yeah and riding on today
which is hot and the horses have all got
sheepskin blankets under their Saddles
and there's all the you can you imagine
the uniforms and they've got bare skin
hats and swords oh astonishing it is a
real feat of endurance and a real source
of Pride for those in the armed forces
taking part today John I just like to
ask because this is the first time we're
seeing you on screen you're gonna be
with us on Sunday as well for the big
parade what this Platinum jubilee mean
to you well it's extraordinary because
69 years ago today the queen was crowned
and I was a little girl out in Malaysia
my father was with his Gurkha regiment
out there and we watched the coronation
on black and white films twice and then
once in color but of course we didn't
know this country we didn't know what
London looked like and on the day of
Coronation it was drizzling and wet and
we looked at these strange gray streets
in this extraordinary ceremony going on
and this tiny figure walking up the
aisle at Westminster Abbey and my heart
just went out even though I was only
seven at the time I just thought this is
one of the most marvelous people in the
world a fairy story yeah and it's lovely
to see now now I understand because I
now know London to know that all these
soldiers are going back to Wellington
Barracks which is only just around the
side we forget them huge Army
Headquarters are here bang in the middle
of London yeah and to tell you being a
Londoner what it's been like preparing
for this with all the streets locked off
for the days in advance now I understand
for the weeks months to make sure that
everything is completely pitch perfect
and press City here and for the security
to the great Royal parks and supreme
Park and Saint James's Park is
extraordinary if the cameras have ever
picked up empty seats there I tell you
what it is it's security saying I'm
sorry where's your accreditation they're
going oh my God so those darling people
are all supposed to be sitting there
sitting in the pot absolutely blocking
the Riser but maybe they'll get you on
the screen and maybe they'll be able to
see yeah they're a big screen that it
screens all over the city for them to
enjoy yeah it has taken people quite a
while to get through Gianna through
security but mainly because she was
having a lot of selfies as well again
like I said it's like we've got royalty
here in the studio and Rihanna the aside
it's from the um uh The Princess and the
two little princes making their first
appearance at a carriage procession what
else stood out for you from trooping the
car well it was interesting what Joanna
was saying about it being so hot and
people having to ride on those horses
amongst them of course were the Prince
of Wales the Duke of Cambridge and and
the Princess Royal and you have to
remember that Prince Charles and
Princess Anne are in their 70s so I
think it was quite remarkable to see
them coming past us and also we've got
to of course talk about the fact that
this was the first moment that we saw
her majesty the queen up on the balcony
and it was confirmed last night that
there were going to be three occasions
that we're going to see her today we've
now seen the first and for me it was it
was wonderful to watch out and you
always see this face on her
really eagle-eyed looking for every
single detail and I've got to stop
looking does she no eyes follow
everything and she was at the end
peeking over the balcony to make sure
that everything was finished before she
then decided to head indoors and those
who organized this amazing spectacle in
the past have taught me that sometimes
certainly when the trooping the color
was at Windsor for the last couple of
years she'd be watching the rehearsals
Through the Windows and they would get
notes back to say well that wasn't quite
right she does not miss a trick there is
no one in the world who has seen so much
pageantry and parade like this and she
knows what she's looking out for but she
was beaming from ear to where you can
see the pictures now look looking for
every single Detail no doubt looking for
her children her grandson to ride back
to Buckingham Palace and Joanna
the Chester Bobby
um the Archbishop was speaking to Kay
Burley earlier on the program and he
talked about the queen and her lifetime
of service
her time as the Monarch and he called it
Flawless which I thought in terms of her
Devotion to the country and her sense of
Duty was a perfect word to sum it up yes
it is and they quite often people used
to say she hasn't put a foot wrong which
is the same as being Flawless and it was
very touching to see a message from
president macron today to say that the
queen is a golden thread that unites our
countries because of course we forget we
were invaded by the French you know for
all that we're an independent country
we've been invaded by everybody and
we've absorbed everybody and we've sent
everybody out of a link to everybody
we've got to remember that this is a
huge family and uh World occasion
actually because the Germans say there
are lots of Queens in the world lots of
rain in Queens but there's only one
Queen and when you talk about the queen
you're talking about this queen
she is truly unique I think amongst two
world leaders and she's living history
people have described directs Brianna
we're talking about
um the the three Royal Riders of course
the great thing is is that when you've
been riding but since practice before
you could walk yes it's no problem yeah
and off you go and the Queen used to
take the the Royal salute side saddle
and the princess Road of course is
riding a stride today but the queen went
on riding side title for a long long
time all the time she'd be there in her
little cat with that blue Bloom and I
had a little lead model of her and it
had a saluting arm which went up like
this I adored it I still got it at home
it's the most adorable little thing oh
you should have lost the horses
[Applause]
but we like that and Rhiannon in terms
of what will be going on now the queen
is not on the balcony anymore she's gone
inside to be with her family and you
have to remember this is also a family
celebration yes
and if we just go back to what we saw on
horse guards parade and the I suppose
that the difficulties for the queen when
it comes to matters around her family
because we can't ignore it it has been a
difficult couple of years and we were
told that Harry and Megan were going to
be with the rest of the family watching
the parade from the major generals
office interestingly we haven't seen any
pictures of them now we were talking
about it earlier they are damned if they
do they're damned if they don't if they
were seen of course they'd be criticized
for overshadowing what is the Queen's
day but then of course there's going to
be questions about why haven't we seen
them in public with the family for the
family third the queen though she
consistently has said they are much
loved members of the family and so
I'm not sure what they'll be a
Buckingham Palace now they may have
managed to get them in there but
certainly there will be family time with
the queen we were saying earlier it's
lillabeth their daughter's birthday on
Saturday they're staying at Windsor so
you'd think that that would be a natural
moment away from away from the public
view yeah I would imagine also have to
mention that um the Duke of York is not
here today and of course there were
questions about whether or not he would
he would appear but um yeah I think for
the queen she wants her family around
her and I think the photograph that we
saw of her that was released it was Les
Regal more grandmotherly I would say and
and that I think is is the message it's
about family is that formal and that
photograph is the photograph of the
dress she's wearing today yes she's just
put a hat on yeah coming out onto the
basket dress it up a little bit just a
hat on I love that I think it's
absolutely beautiful because she always
has to wear eye-catching things that you
would notice her and you'd see this tiny
figure on the balcony and you know at
once it's the queen don't you she does
stands out and rightly so and as you can
see from your screens there we are
waiting for that 82 gun salute to Mark
the Queen's Platinum Jubilee that is
another big event of the day we are
standing by for that and while we do um
we're going to bring in our Royal
commentator Alistair Bruce he has hot
footed up three flights of stairs by may
I say where he was in a little
commentary box uh telling us all about
the trooping the color Alistair you've
regained your breath welcome back up
here to our balcony opposite the
Buckingham Palace balcony it seemed to
go extremely well from our point of view
but you have the Goliath how did it go
for you it was absolutely wonderful I
loved it Joanna lovely to see you
it's absolutely fantastic I think every
single Guardsman and Trooper out there
every non-commissioned officer and every
officer should be really proud of the
result of the hard work they've put in
since pretty much April to try and make
that the very best they could for this
Platinum Jubilee moment and seeing the
queen on it is quite difficult to see
her out there but seeing the queen up on
the balcony it would have meant a great
deal to her troops that she has led for
70 years came again to make salute to
her I thought it was marvelous
the queen means so many things to so
many different people but as head of the
Armed Forces I was speaking to an army
veteran Carol Betteridge for our Sky
News podcast this week it was all about
people who have met the queen and she
was awarded by the queen and she says
that she refers to her as the boss as so
many people in the Army lots of people
do because that is such a big part of
who the Monarch is I know it's
extraordinary though isn't it when you
think of it she's ahead of so many
things she's head of the Church of
England she's head of the army she's
head of she's head off she's head off
she can't be it's not a popularity
contest you're not voted in and voted
out you simply assume the role and when
as a little girl she knew she would be
Queen and then when eventually she was
26 she was crowned queen she took all
this on her little little slim shoulders
and I'm sure we've all seen recently
that gorgeous little home movie issue
and we realized how much Slimmer we all
were
tiny slim and gorgeously shaped to us
how very beautiful she and Princess
Margaret were and how I don't know how
long ago that was you think and she's
been there without a hitch all this time
quite extraordinary I think what
fascinates me is that every single day
she gets the red boxes they come on
every day except actually for Mondays
because no one fills one for her on a
Sunday and she goes through them and she
is a part of the function of government
every part of her life so she can't ever
take a day off or relax completely she's
always got to do her bit and I think
that on an occasion like this where she
is the figurehead of so many troops it
matters so much that she managed to get
here and they'll all be pleased I mean
eyes right I know when because when
you're a soldier and you've given eyes
right and they'll look straight up and
at the balcony and there is the queen
that's what it was all for what you
serve with I was with the Scots guards
oh were you but I served with the gurkas
you'll be pleased
yes exactly this has got to be one of
the most extraordinary days to be here
isn't it in our lifetime and probably in
many people's lifetimes when is it ever
going to happen again I think lots of
people will will think well we've seen
this before we've seen troop in the
color we've seen concerts outside of
Buckingham Palace we've done the street
parties we've done jubilees
but you can't overstate that Britain has
never seen A Moment Like This no
Platinum Jubilee and the fact that we
had such a young Queen who has enjoyed
very good health throughout her Reign
means that we're unlikely to see a
platinum Jubilee again for a very long
time so let's soak it up let's enjoy it
and um yeah make it the moment that it
should be yeah and Joanna I know that
you were briefly chatting to people as
you made your way with the crowd like
everyone else to get here today
what kind of sense did you get for
people from people because they've come
from all over the world we were down on
the mall earlier to be from Canada
America and Malaysia all across the
world to come and be here thrilling and
of course people had said earlier on
before when I knew I was going to be
honored by allowing to speak
um they said and you go by tube and I
said oh really oh not a huge chauffeur
driven limo no you just literally won't
get there too and the tube was alive
with people they were already in the
tube station they were saying be careful
use all the exits and cross the road
outside because people could hardly get
out of the station it was so full and
then outside the streets were
deserted except for millions of people
if you know what I mean there's hardly
any traffic going down Piccadilly and
people crossing over and taking pictures
and smiling there were people with
babies in pushchairs people with picnics
and sandwiches and and flags and strange
funny hats there were people running in
high heels thinking they'd come to the
wrong gate it was just a sense of such
festivity and I hope that will continue
I know it's going to rain but we're all
the gardens want that and the queen is a
very keen Gardener so she'll be pleased
is it a garden party or a street party
Without Rain I know exactly you've got
to get the Lily out haven't you it
rained on her coronation I mean it was
one of the coldest June days ever they'd
chosen the second of June here we are on
the 2nd of June in 1953 because it
looked to be the day most likely to have
good weather of course it being Britain
it didn't quite live up to the mock and
you look at the pictures of the
coronation in 1953 it's drenching down
and yet all the way up and down the mall
and the procession was four and a half
hours for the queen right out through
London and nobody seemed to mind well
who can forget the Diamond Jubilee
flotilla on the Thames the boats um and
also her 90th birthday as well a huge
lunch along the mile tipped it down so
anyway hopefully the pageants will go
without him people get into the spirit
exactly and we are in a very privileged
position to be here today and those who
have managed to make it to the city of
London to watch what's going on all day
today is you know again very privileged
but up and down the country there will
be parties people will be tuning in on
television across the Commonwealth as
well Joanna you know this is being
marked worldwide I know it's absolutely
wonderful they'll all be seeing it at
different times of their days and nights
but sitting up maybe to watch it and uh
we had some very very keen people in our
Square our garden Square in South
Londonderry which started
closely on some white wine at about 10
o'clock this morning and I thought hmm
I'm not sure if that's gonna work all
the way through the day
if some people want to do that and the
great thing about it I'm Platinum
Jubilee is everyone can do precisely
what they want yes some people will pay
absolutely no attention to it at all
yeah how very British that is some
people have gone abroad and probably
caught poor things a lot of people
working this weekend of course well
that's right you and me yeah yeah but
yes yes yeah we are and you know
solidarity with everyone working over
this four day uh weekend it's not a full
day holiday for everybody but you can
follow all these celebrations right here
on Sky News
um Rhiannon what can we expect for the
rest of the weekend because we've um had
the main part of today we are waiting
for the 82 gun salute we're very much
looking forward to that but talk us
through what else will be happening oh
my goodness we're going to have a huge
Bounty of Royal events it just keeps on
keeps on going so um we'll have the gun
salute shortly then we will see working
members the royal family appear on the
balcony with the queen so that
spectacular fly pass by the RAF Alice
don't expect you to be spotting all the
different planes I'm ready for that
because how many of them are there
around seven quite a lot yeah yeah
the wonderful thing will be when the
Lancaster bomber comes home from the
Battle of Britain Memorial flight the
sound it's got a real throat and when
that comes over here I think for people
of the Queen's generation they will
remember the excitement they felt when
they saw them heading over to Germany to
try and stop the second world war as
early as it could be those Brave Pilots
also the Spitfire and everything else
now this means that you can see an
arrival of the great sea of people who
want to come and support them so it'll
gradually filling up so gradually it'll
all be filling up around the Victoria
Memorial indeed absolutely and look
they've got police walking quietly in
France the horses in front and here come
people and people and people and they
can break out both ways here and go to
the left and right of the of the Queen
Victoria Memorial to just squashing at
the front they're gonna have to go right
in the center I think to get a really
good view of the balcony but they'll all
have a good time remember which Jubilee
it was when Concord was still flying and
she came down over the mall
it was the lowest you've ever flown and
I live over the river and I was watching
it from the attic and she came along and
because she couldn't maintain that Pike
I followed by the Red Arrows it was
thrilling look at them oh so look we've
got some of the Boy Scouts would it be
Cadets down there yeah it looks cadets
at the front
Cadets
[Applause]
instructors too look at that
and that's the younger generation
[Applause]
which is a real theme this weekend of
course and the audience will around here
getting to their feet to applaud them
which is very very nice
and for the queen of course we will talk
endlessly about what has been a
remarkable 70-year Reign for her though
the central themes are service and Duty
not just hers but also those who serve
their country in their own ways and
that's what we're seeing here younger
people who are involved in in
volunteering who do their bits to help
people around them and that I think is a
really lovely it's lovely theme it's
recognition that it's just so richly
deserved look at it it's divine I'm
being told we have around 30 seconds
until until the guys
and which Park do they they far from
they're just down there in Green Park
for an 82 gun salute that's two times 21
because it's the
official birthday of the queen and also
the coronation anniversary and then an
extra 20 guns twice because they're
being fired in a Royal Park
wow this is a scene from Hyde Park
[Music]
they don't have anything in the garden
to count exactly 82.
now this has to be complete by
a minute to one o'clock because at that
point we will see the skies fill with
aircraft
Heathrow will have been closed
in order to see the waves come across of
the aircraft
[Music]
foreign
earlier on today at the end of
the Queen's birthday parade
[Applause]
meanwhile proud outside Buckingham
Palace is building steadily
answers
[Music]
it seems a great sea of people coming
down
from the far end of the mall these are
people who have waited patiently in
order to wish the queen a very happy
passing Jubilee there's some cheering
behind me and I'm sure that's only going
to get louder
but meanwhile the guns are firing
and they're also doing so in other parts
of the United Kingdom Belfast Cardiff
Colchester in Edinburgh where my own
castle I'm the governor there 105
regiment Royal artillery will be firing
a 42 gun salute in Gibraltar and
Stonehenge
and Plymouth and that's his Naval Base
there Portsmouth 2 Sterling
York museum an onboard ship HMS Prince
of Wales will be firing HMS Portland HMS
Kent
first two of those ships the first in
south of Plymouth at Sea and the other
at anchor off tall Bay and finally ships
alongside in foreign ports in Stockholm
HMS Defender and HMS Montrose in Bahrain
the party officer of the King Street
Royal Horse artillery who is Major Fran
psych she must be immensely proud of the
preparation made by 170 of her personnel
and there were 120 horses on Parade
but my goodness look at the multitude
coming down the mall a wonderful sight
indeed
so these guns that
new action in the first world war
between 1914 and 18.
and yet are so beautifully cared for and
looked after the cries getting more and
more excited as they get closer and
closer to the Palace meanwhile inside
the queen and other members of the world
family will be watching coverage of this
as they all reassemble after returning
from horse guards
as I was saying the front of Buckingham
Palace is a building site at the moment
and that's why all the windows are
blocked off with blue coverings because
inside enormous amounts of work are
being done but there has been a special
route made through the building site for
the queen and working members of the
royal family to reach the balcony in a
few minutes time
[Applause]
I guess he comes
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the queen looked down from this balcony
with her father at the end of the second
world war in 1945. she looked at at the
end of her coronation in 1953
69 years ago today but here after 70
years as our Sovereign the queen with
the working members of her family who
support her in her role she's getting a
huge happy birthday
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
the guns will go on firing for another
two minutes and then the sky will be
filled with the noise of aircraft past
and present
to salute Her Majesty from the Royal Air
Force and from the Battle of Britain
historic Memorial flight
Queen is holding a stick that was given
to her by the Army as a present for her
Platinum Jubilee
as the first wave with a wildcat
helicopter which is escorted here by two
Merlin helicopters these aircraft that
know
capabilities that they have in time of
battle
and you can see the waves coming for
next wave two another wildcat with three
Apache helicopters
very shortly the royal family will see
above
the great golden symbol of Victory those
aircraft heading towards them
I can certainly hear them myself
[Music]
so from the Royal Navy that first wave
from well Naval Air Station at yeovilton
will be shortly above us as the guns
complete their firing
[Music]
it was very difficult to assess quite
how high these aircraft are but I'll
tell you they are as low as they are
allowed and they can see the Queen's
eyes from where they're sitting in their
cockpits to see from each aircraft and
overcomes the first wave
[Music]
wave two which is one British Army
wildcat with three British Army Apaches
come on Ron Naval Air Station Yoga
Center and also a Watterson flying
school
and wave three
one Wild
helicopter with three million
helicopters again
and then wave four three Puma
helicopters and three massive synoks
there's a really deep down draft and
Rumble as they go over here and it's
fantastic but look perhaps one of the
greatest sights of all from the Battle
of Britain flight coming towards us now
and for the queen and her generation as
they see this great Lancaster bomber
flanked by three Spitfires and two
hurricanes what a great sight
I think two Spitfires maybe one of them
wasn't up to Snuff this morning but look
at them flying over now the roar listen
to it brings back memories of 1939 to
45.
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
from those memories of her childhood
when London faced the Blitz and danger
was everywhere and yet overcome and at
greater speed now
one Venom and four Texans Roar across
wave seven and the Workhorse of the
royal Air Force which has helped deploy
troops to challenges all over the world
supporting the Royal Navy the Royal Air
Force and also the Army in its tasks
three Hercules
we'll hear that role
then in wave a lofty and transient in
the sight that they give us all here in
London a massive Atlas and Globe Master
C-17 again these great workhorses that
have played their part in supporting the
Armed Forces
[Music]
I'm sorry if I'm getting excited but the
sound of that Roar is so fantastic and I
remember it from times I've needed to
see those aircraft in the sky when
deployed and wave nine a Poseidon and a
rivet joint
these aircraft that keep us safe they
listen they look and they make sure that
we know where danger lies
[Music]
I think the Queen's loving us as much as
we are as she has seen so many of these
aircraft particularly when she's visited
a literary organizations throughout her
reign
wave 10 is a voyager at lightning and a
typhoon and remember all these aircraft
had to be timed at different stages
[Applause]
[Music]
four Lightnings supporting it
[Music]
as each of them lifts away and makes its
way towards
the airflow system that needs to get
into to get out of the way
Royal Air Force VIP by Enterprise
I think the
third life of London's all flown away I
saw them leave after the first wave it's
a marvelous Lord of each of them coming
over wave 12 is four Hawks
attack aircraft
find that quite noisy
and here we are at 70 7-0 wave 13 15
typhoon aching the mark of the Queen's
70 years of sovereign
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
and here they come the red arrows in red
white and blue filling the sky with the
great salute of the three national
colors
the queen Platinum Jubilee
commander-in-chief
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
a national anthem for her majesty from
the new guard and the Old Guard who are
in the process of handing over the new
guard we saw troop the color earlier on
before the Irish grass the queen
leaving
[Applause]
the Duke of Kent and the Earl of Wessex
last leave of the Royal Family
as
the pages close the windows and that
balcony appearance is done
that really was rather special wasn't it
Aleister I think the only person that
matched your enthusiasm and excitement
was Little Prince Louis
you know what once sees there as a
salute to the queen but they're working
out
that if you're a soldier on the ground
or you're out at Sea and you need help
when you see those come over you know
you're safe and it's a sign I think of
the protection and the importance of
protecting the kingdom and where the
queen forms the leadership role in that
it has effect and it matters to soldiers
Sailors air men and women yeah Joanna
very symbolic yeah but very special the
crowd here
love that they just adored it and
they're a little small it's a group
setting up either to do three chairs or
to sing Happy Birthday or just to just
generally do a lovely sort of shout it
was almost like a Mexican wave of sounds
happening all around the place and the
other thing to remember of course is
that all the soldiers are serving
soldiers it's not just ceremonial it's
it's something extraordinary all those
men marching and riding and drive
playing and you know they're all working
soldiers so it's terrific I just adore
it I love it I love the pageantry I hope
this never stops and I think the world
loves a bit of bling you know what I
mean you want a massive Mega bling every
time
just a bit of Sparkle cheers us up right
yes bit of Sparkle juices up and Rihanna
can we talk about who was on the balcony
because there was so much talk in the
build up to this we were told by the
palace it would be working Royals what
did we see up there today and that's
exactly what we saw I think it was the
queen saying her own thank you to those
members of the family sorry my
microphone's just slipping off those
members of the family who day to day
travel up and down the country across
the Commonwealth planting the trees
cutting the ribbons doing the duties
that she can't carry out anymore and so
for her it was really important to yeah
have them all around her say thank you
allow them to have that moment in the
public eye
um but also I think for the family it's
it's one of those moments where they
also want to come together to mark this
truly unique moment and and what I
always love about that balcony moment is
yes you literally have thousands of
people standing there watching them it's
being beamed live around the world on
television and yet you still have those
funny little family interactions that
you'd get with any family at home oh
look at that one look at that go there
you've got Prince Louis speaking to the
Queen the queen obviously saying oh this
is this is this this is the other and um
and so that is what I really enjoy is
that ultimately in some ways the the
sort of mask drops and and they enjoy it
as a family unit and of course front and
center is the queen who was with their
sunglasses on keeping a close eye on
what was flying over but um yeah seemed
to be thoroughly enjoying it and and I
think after all of the concerns that we
may not see her this weekend and
obviously concerns about her health
wasn't it amazing to see her her looking
so well and just enjoying enjoying this
moment it was it was wonderful and
Joanna this weekend is a lot about uh
reflection in terms of the queen and her
service and Duty
but there's a very subtle look towards
the future as well in terms of the
working members of the royal family
she's surrounded herself with and her
great grandchildren we saw in the
carriage procession there's a look ahead
to what the monarchy will be like for
for future years when um when the Queen
Mother
was widowed she made a speech to the
Nation about her daughter she said I
present to my daughter who
um to the great and lonely position to
which she is being called she will need
your prayers and your protection and
your love and I think that that's what
this queen would be saying about the
Next Generation it's going to be handed
on this is a monarchy until it isn't
monarchy it is a monarchy and So
eventually one day there will be King
Charles eventually will be King William
King George whatever titles or names
they choose to have it will go on until
it doesn't go on and until that point I
think we've just got to do our level
best to support and love and protect
them actually not be beastly now is the
time not to be beastly to anybody
actually Alistair you'll never Beastie
to anyone you're the nicest man probably
you don't see me at home I'll vouch for
that because what viewers didn't see was
when Rihanna was having problems
behind you trying to help him yes
um can't we just talk about
um Giovanni you wrote a book in the the
build up to this Platinum Jubilee and
you collected stories yes from people of
all ages from all over the country and
the Commonwealth and you know you always
hear the phrase the Royals they're not
like us
but when you meet a member of the royal
family particularly the Queen the story
that you always get is that actually on
a certain level she is she talks to you
exactly like you're on her level she's
very amenable very uh Pleasant you know
I spoke to somebody that met her um for
a podcast they said she had good banter
which I love yes very nice I think
they're so warm and friendly and
remember they've been doing this for a
long long time and I think that people
are always stunned by meeting members of
royal family because you're so nervous
and you're so anxious should you bow or
curtsy or not and should it be too deep
and must you start speaking or not start
speaking or you know should you say your
Royal Highness and Sir or should you say
yes sir and then people get tongue-tied
a bit tongue-tied but the Royal Family
are just to a person so charming and so
ease making they make you at once feel
like that you are special and belong to
them and it could be and a friend I find
it just it's wonderful and that's partly
training but it's partly a sense of
confidence in who they are and putting
themselves in other people I know that
the queen and Prince Philip never looked
in they were always looking out and
looking out for other people so he said
look up and look out don't look down and
look in and I think that's the rule by
which they've lived their lives and you
were invited to one of their lunches I
was indeed yes intimate lunches that the
queen and Prince Philip decided that
they wanted to have so that they could
get a sense of how people were feeling
about life in the world yes and what was
it like what was that that's just it's
extraordinary because you're in
Buckingham Palace but you're in the
private part where there's a beautiful
yellow drawing room which looks out over
the Gardens at the back and it's the
homely part of it there's a dining room
you're treated as a complete friend it's
just a lovely comfortable sitting room
with a fire and homemade kind of home
arranged flowers as it were and the
queen comes in with a little flurry of
corgis around her feet and the brightest
smile because this is her home and she
says how lovely to see you
it was just
and this is what Terry wogan the great
Terry wogan late now
um said that you begin to it's the Royal
effect you immediately begin to talk
absolute rubbish and I don't know why
but the queen so kindly came up to me
and said
um do tell me what's occupying you at
the moment and for some reason and
because this had never really been in my
head at all I said I'm very interested
in the decriminalization of drugs
and she's just a moment of something it
might have even been humor flicked
across her face she said to God
why did I even say that I can't think
anyway she saved me and she was
wonderful she was just adorable and then
I heard the most extraordinary words I'd
never hear again in my life the queen
turning to me and saying should we go
into lunch
and the answer that is so lovely yes
yeah oh what a what a special memory and
I I love that it's tinged with a lot of
humor as well because Alistair
um there is a a lot of humor to the
queen which obviously we don't really
get a sense of at these official
occasions but behind the scenes we hear
that she has got a good humor she's very
close uh to younger members of the royal
family in particular bridging that
generational Gap she's a fabulous mimic
and she's got very good timing and she
knows that she's often surrounded by an
environment of tension which China was
explaining and the best way to puncture
that she had a great guide in all of
this which was her husband Prince Philip
he was brilliant just knocking away any
form of pomposity or seriousness he got
into quite a lot of trouble for it
because he very often said things that
people saw as difficult or whatever but
for the queen she's always used his
timing herself very well and remember
you know very often going into difficult
situations
she uses her dogs too you were talking
about them appearing just before she
came around the corner and I think those
dogs often deal with the fact the queen
can be quite shy because at heart I was
asked the other day what single word
would you use to describe the queen and
I said humble which may be quite an odd
word but it's because she is quite shy
and she knows that she's not Queen
because she came top of anything she's
not Queen because she won anything or
she was particularly brilliant or or
whatever she's Queen because she was
George VI's eldest daughter and that's
why whenever people try and go oh you
are the most wonderful this and the
other she's not interested in any of
that she doesn't like that and so when
people are nervous with her she looks to
the dogs and starts saying oh well this
one's called this one's called and
suddenly you're talking about the dogs
you're not dealing with the head of
state someone who's been on the throne
now for 70 years yeah even this year
just her sense of humor coming out for
example Onyx session weekend where she
hosted people at Sandringham house there
was this huge cake and it was basically
turned the wrong way round for her to
see it and someone explained to her well
it's for the cameras and she said well I
don't matter do I the whole room erupted
the G7 Summit last year as well all of
the leaders sitting there around her and
all of a sudden she said well are we
meant to smile and again Gales have
laughed around and he's just those
little quips she seems to be she seems
to be enjoying life in her 90s and um
and that's lovely to see for example at
the winter Horse Show and um and again
on the balcony today
at the state opening of parliament I I
dress as one of the Heralds and I I lead
the procession into the Lord so you get
a very close view of the queen and she
had the crown on and all the robes and
she was due to fly off on a state visit
and she said my lords and members of the
House of Commons the Duke of Edinburgh
and I are going
this afternoon
as if to point time that you know I'm
trying to put all this off I'm still
going to get on the plane and go
somewhere so she's got moments of yeah
of humor that worked really well in very
public moments and I think that also she
showed that when she accepted in a
nanosecond to do that James Bond spoof
thing oh yeah because I don't think
Danny Boyle was even I think he was
asking whether they get somebody who
looked like the queen to do it she said
I will do that I'll do that because of
London
Olympic ceremony and then she kept it
Deadly Secret from her family knowing
that it would be a huge surprise and a
shock to them to see it I just think it
was I think Mary shouted go granny
absolutely very very charming and I
think that that sort of got under the
skin of everybody watching it because we
all adore James Bond the idea of seeing
actual James James or actual Danny Craig
with the real corgis and you go oh to my
days apparently at the stadium they kept
her in a box so she never saw that she
know I mean she'd seen it all been put
together but they kept her in a box so
that she'd come out with the head of the
Olympics yes she never actually thought
she could hear the raw roll actually
probably heard the rules here yes but
that also you know when you're in that
situation you'd think you see everything
and she probably doesn't see you as much
as we think she sees
I love the idea that she was sitting
being painted for some by Pietro aragoni
who did one of the most famous paintings
portraits of her standing sideways in a
long dark cloak when she was very young
with her brown hair painting it in one
in the yellow drawing room which is
right at the front here and the queen
was sitting by the window and she could
look out here and in the olden days in
the olden days sweethearts when when you
could drive around the Victoria Memorial
which you can't know because it's just
any of them out um she looked out and
there was a slight shunt a taxi and a
car had a slight Biff like this the
queen watched it with the greatest
interest taxi driver got out man from
car garage and you had an altercation
change things like they said earlier
this is going to cost the passenger
quite a lot and you never think of the
queen watching us yeah you think of us
watching her and she's looking back at
us imagine if you're that Taxi Driver
watching at home now listening to that
story there have probably been a few
shots outside here the traffic could be
terrible and in terms of let's talk
about embracing the younger Generations
because the queen has adapted and she is
willing to embrace anything from new
technology to new ideas I've heard a lot
from young people um who have received
honors from the queen over the last few
days talking about
when they met her and what she talked to
them about she's very invested in so
many different things and alive to
change as it was I think he's so
interested in everything she seems to be
curious about everything remember she's
almost the most travel person any of us
will ever know she's met more presidents
and prime ministers she's had more of
everything she's open more hospitals
planted more trees we've heard she's
receivable bouquets she's sat through
more speeches than anybody else on Earth
actually
and she's become fascinated and I would
have said almost an expert in all kinds
of things including of course he never
dabbles in politics but I would imagine
pretty far far up the political tree of
every country actually and reading those
papers particularly commonwealth
countries and places she visits they do
a lot of work behind the scenes before
they go out they didn't just go out and
say hello they've got to know what's
going on in that country and and who
stands for who and that goes for the
Charities and ngos that he goes for
everything so hugely hugely wise woman
we've got a wise woman we've got a
Mothership
good description yeah I'm just looking
at some of the the facts that were put
out by the palace
um ahead of this Jubilee the queen has
carried out more than 21
000 engagements over the course of her
Reign
um Her Majesty has held over 50 ranks
and appointments in the British
Commonwealth armed services during her
lifetime
I mean when you just look at some of
these facts on pay balusters Rihanna
touched on before so the likes of which
we will never see again in this country
this Monarch this rain
well we're all part of it you see her
Reign has encompassed everybody here
everybody here who's used to stamp or
pay for something with a note or a coin
or whatever
or gone to a post box and seen the crime
that it's everywhere and the queen has
been the personification of it it just
happens that I think she's done a
remarkably good job fate might have
given us anybody but it gave us
Elizabeth II and I think that she has
delivered against a pretty tall order
I'm very moved by the regalia used in
her coronation because if you lay it all
out
it will give just as much guidance to
somebody running a shop in East London
or in the north of Scotland or out in
the eye to Hebrides as it does to a
sovereign it teaches you how to how to
behave in a position of leadership and I
think the queen took all that very
seriously and basically it's all about
if you lead putting yourself last and
don't you think it's one of the
loneliest places in the world because I
see when you walk around everyone wants
to have a bit of you
and that must make you a bit lonely in a
funny story
it doesn't because I am not wrong I'm
not the queen but B because people know
me as a friend on television they know
what I sound like and they treat me as a
friend which is quite different they
feel tongue-tied when they come up to
you they talk about all sorts I've seen
it I think if you are in a position
where everyone's got something to gain
from you yeah it does mean that it's
more difficult in a way to find a place
where where your yourself yeah the past
prime ministers often talk about how
they obviously have those weekly
audiences with her every Wednesday and
what is said in that room stays in that
room and she has this this appreciation
that no one else possibly can that it
can be very lonely at the top and and so
they see her as this amazing sounding
board and and also Tony Blair recently
said to me that she also appreciates
that behind the position there is a
person and so there would be questions
about the family and what else was going
on not just kind of the matters of of
stakeholders the business of the day and
and so I think that's why she's been so
incredible and that's why I think world
leaders hold her up as this woman
without equal they have so much respect
for her and again last year at the G7
Summit you had the likes of macron
Trudeau Boris Johnson all falling over
themselves Angela Merkel to spend that
little bit of time with her because I
think they appreciate that they can
learn so much from a woman who has just
seen this extraordinary period of social
political and and economic change and we
continue to go through phases of change
now so not to bring the tone down but
things like the metoo movement black
lives matter these are all things that
the royal family have to contend with
just like the rest of us and and that's
what she's doing day to day that's what
the family are doing day to day by
engaging on issues like mental health
the environment and I think we'll see a
lot of that as well this weekend it's
about engaging it's about learning from
people not necessarily always getting it
right but trying to listen to see where
they can remain relevant and move
forward with the rest of us I suppose
and can we just talk to her about yeah a
strong female figurehead because after
the queen comes Prince Charles and
Prince William this is
this is incredible in terms of to have a
woman
since her early twenties
she knew it she had from everybody who
seems to know her or knew her intimately
since she was a child they said that as
a child she had a quite just serious and
responsible Outlook she was older than
her sister a lovely naughty cheeky
Little Princess Margaret Rose who was
the Scamp and the queen was the one who
kept things in order and did things
properly you can imagine that in that
great and lonely stationed when she's
been called one of the one of the huge
reliefs is to be with dogs and horses
who don't know who you are and don't
care who you are and treat you normally
but also I think it's interesting how
she is she's trying to elevate Other
Women Within the family so the accession
Day message was really telling where she
basically said for the first time I want
the Duchess of Cornwall to be Queen when
my son becomes king she should be Queen
and so I think she sees it as her role
to elevate other members of the royal
family not just those within that direct
line of succession and well I'm here
with our Royal correspondent Rihanna
Mills and Joanna Lumley and we're also
joined Now by Colonel Edward bellito
lordly tenant uh of Cornwall chairman
Association of the Lord a lieutenant and
good to see you thank you so much for
joining us here on Sky News what have
you made of the day so far let's start
with that well I started this morning
right earlier in in West Cornwall oh my
goodness sunny it's very very peaceful
suddenly had said people that traveled
for miles
and to arrive here in London to find and
I was in London last week and it was
fairly quiet and I think you've come to
London now the station of the Fall the
trains of all the streets are full and
you've got this humongous throng of
people around here it's it's really
quite um it's moving it's very very
moving yes and what we haven't mentioned
is that there's a kind of press
but it's lovely because circle around
here are a whole lot of similar people
like us all faces we know and you can
look across
and there's somebody else doing a direct
thing to camera like this and depending
on which channel you are you'll find one
of us I love it it's a feeling of
comradeship it's drawn all of us
together you know I so agree because and
I think what you know whatever Herman
actually brings is a huge man it's this
business of continuity and unity which I
think is really really important I think
as a sort of species the human race
likes that it likes to have the
continuity in the know about its
ancestors and what's to come and I think
the queen really brings that to us so
strongly we're so lucky to have her and
you're the Queen's personal
representative as it were as Lord
lieutenant in Cornwall can you tell us a
bit about your role
well the queen appoints one of us for
each of the counties of the United
Kingdom and we are her representatives
in there and that means we do formal
things on her her behalf because you
also can't get it other times like
um organizing Royal visits
um presenting Awards
um and what we mainly do I think is the
is the other royal family role there's
some the nationhood role of trying to
get to know organizations and people
without within our counties to be able
to thank them for what they're doing and
be sure and interest in what they're
doing and try and join up the dots so
all get organizations are inclined to
work in a little Alleyways to to work
better for each other and it's an
incredibly rewarding job yeah it's so
interesting that the queen obviously has
so many duties and so many roles to be
across she really does have a massive
team behind her how much contact do you
have with the queen herself uh
occasionally it has to be said but um
you know she's obviously getting around
less than she was
um but I I was lucky enough to have a
video call with her last year and of
course she came down with four other
members of her family to the G7 event in
in Cornwall which is simply
extraordinary day as extraordinary today
um and she's always giving us messages
and all that sort of thing so we get
quite a bit from her
the um the tree of trees the Lord
lieutenants are also involved in where
the trees go aren't they we are there
are 300 the tree of trees is going to be
the Principal Beacon which we lit up
this evening and there are over 300
trees
the Lord lieutenants have been asked for
advice on where those trees should be
dispatched after the weekend so I think
four are coming to Cornwall and we're
gonna have to find really suitable
places I'm sure trees I hope the trees
will grow up for 200 years
simply extraordinary he did for the um
Olympics the great the great cauldron
which turned it which all those petals
all turned into that great cauldron he's
a genius boy Thomas hellowick apologies
if I seem slightly distracted walking
behind me I'm being told by my producer
uh that Prince Charles and Camilla are
doing a walkabout in the crowds I'm sort
of just trying to train my eye to find a
huddle of police officers uh protection
officers to see where they might be but
I understand they're out greeting the
crowds you of course we haven't some of
them have been here since the early
hours of Tuesday morning oh yeah well I
was down here last night and the tents
were out and it was at that point that
it struck me I was like wow okay the
crowds really do want to get that front
row seat for this moment in history and
as they have done for the coronation and
all of her other jubilees I have to say
what is always interesting about Prince
Charles and Camilla is they like to get
stuck in when it comes to a crowd they
probably will have seen the crowds and
thought right I want to go out there and
and go and meet people and you probably
see that all the time down in college
they're brilliant they come down
50 yards can take half an hour yeah
every single person and just like his
father whenever he leaves people they're
always they're always smiling they're
always laughing and he's he's incredibly
interested in he doesn't say whatsoever
like he really gets stuck in and finds
out about them which is very very
impressive actually yeah the pictures
you can see here
um actually John is what you were
talking about this is the little media
Village
um
but they're just coming through that
back entrance that's the security points
we were talking about where we had to
show all our accreditation yes and so
that's the due to Duchess of Cornwall
there in those cars I'm not too sure
where we're headed to keep an eye on
them yeah yeah they probably didn't mean
to come and see us
Joanna but in terms of um obviously the
Duke and Duchess of four Wall playing a
big role
um in the area and you said in the
Grenadier guards
I just want to ask your thoughts on
trooping the color today as part of the
Platinum league is what we witnessed
here it was just incredible I I remember
doing it myself a long long time ago and
when you left the parade Square you felt
about 20 feet tall it was absolutely
wonderful and how much more so it must
have been for the guys on today because
you know with all these vast Prides and
the knowledge that this is a completely
unique event I don't know they were they
won't walk on the ground for weeks
afterwards
do you get nervous before of certainly
yeah I'm I'm not alone because a million
a million viewers will have seen there
was a ride on his horse and I pretty
much adore that I love riding the sauces
anyway but I wonder who which poor chap
was not on his horse and will he will he
be Scarlet with shame forevermore well I
think these things happen I think the
television camera is very decently they
didn't went away from it
now there's a thing called the
dismounted Officers Club which is for
those officers who have had the
misfortune to um
quite serious but I hope you'll be all
right I think you'll be fine but the
truth is it must have been thrilling for
the queen who loves horses so deeply
that she's called by her own Headroom
the equine Queen she knows there's
nothing about horses she doesn't know
and to see them behaving so beautifully
today and we all have our favorites and
I particularly adore the great drum
horses those huge heavy horses oblivious
to sound they've all been trained so
shouts and noise and the sound of bands
and instruments playing nothing phases
them and off they go absolutely gorgeous
and I'm sure her majesty will enjoy it
if someone fell off time they're quite
like a little mistakes
it comes back to that sense of humor
about before when things go wrong the
right smile or a raise of the eyebrow is
all we need and Rihanna remind us where
we go from this point in because
obviously we've had all the official
part of the day so far what happens next
I feel a bit exhausted so it's all been
it's all been too much already but no it
keeps going and and also for the queen
it keeps going so this evening we're
going to see beacons being lit across
the country as I said the tree of trees
is going to be the Principal Beacon and
she will appear outside Windsor Castle
not sure how it's going to work but with
the joys of Technology she will press
something it'll set off an amazing light
display and then the tree of trees back
here will be lit up and Prince William
will be there to make sure that it all
goes to plan and then what beacons lit
all around the country absolutely it's
lovely it's how they pass messages in
the old days wasn't it I think they
could get from Plymouth to London in
about seven minutes
and what was it you saw the bonfire and
you licked your own and then they saw
your bonfire so you're always on
something which is why there are lots of
places called Beacon Hill which is where
there's absolutely right I mean
cornwalling I'm from Michael's mind to
the top
so that's another way of kind of
bringing the country together and then
of course we move on to Friday where we
have a service of Thanksgiving where
again we're hoping to see the queen we
know that um she won't have to walk up
that enormous flight of steps into Saint
Paul's they've worked out another way
that she can get in if she does want to
attend I think that again will be a big
family family occasion uh there'll be a
reception at the uh the Guild Hall and
then we move on to Saturday big concert
here at Buckingham Palace will the queen
go to the derby who knows we know as you
were saying she loves her horses and
then Sunday of course is another huge
day praying that we won't get too much
rain yeah
um but it's going to be color people
Carnival it's going to be amazing all
around the mall around the palace
um lots of National Treasures and um
Joanna's gonna join us as well
I'm so touched and thrilled and I can't
wait to see it because I think we're
going to see the golden carriage State
Carriage it will be empty but it's going
to be dragged through and of course that
Bewitched me when I was only a child and
I had a little again a little lead model
of it little golden Carriage with the
horses at the front I just was so
thrilled I get to see it with my real
own eyes yeah again they're going to use
technology to we don't know how but try
and bring that moment to life for a new
generation
I don't think so an avatar of the queen
we're keeping some things up there
thank you so much for um popping in to
talk to us today enjoy the celebrations
in Cornwall I know they'll be
celebrating all weekend as well
celebration no no I'm going to suppose
now because I'm putting another uniform
tomorrow and dressing up for the for the
services and supports in a red tunic and
Tin helmet with feathers on top of a
year that's you yeah it could be a few
of those thank you very much enjoy the
rest of the weekend we're gonna head
down to the Mal now uh shinky marike is
down with a crowd soaking up the
atmosphere hi shiggy
hi Sarah Jane yes it's been a fantastic
day for the people out on the mall here
we watch them walk towards where we're
stood and watch the fly past I think
you'll probably struggle to hear me over
this but we've got someone now coming
back down the mall uh and we're having a
look now at this this musicians playing
as well and people walking back around
but um we had the chance to speak to
quite a few people here a couple from
Newcastle who said that this was one of
their first times in London seeing the
trooping the color and it was just a
sense of collective War across the cloud
everyone looked up when the fly past
happened some people had their phones
out some people were waving British
flags and there were cheers that went up
as they watched those planes go by a lot
of people had the same kind of
enthusiasm that we heard Alistair Bruce
talking about those planes with as well
it was it was definitely reflected here
too and then they walked towards the
mall as well and they got the chance to
try and catch a glimpse of the royal
family on the balcony as well and it's
quite a moment watching them all open up
to members of the public and then they
just walked through they came through
streams and you can see them there there
are horses out in front and you can see
lots of people craning their necks to
get a look at who might be coming by but
it's it's it's it's been a really really
interesting occasion I got the chance to
go down and speak to a person as well
who's been to various Royal occasions
they described coming to the Diamond
Jubilee as well they were a Chinese
student at the time they're now living
in London and they wanted to come and
catch a glimpse of the jubilees as well
follow the direction of police and shoes
we could we can hear we can we can see
people waiting for someone else to come
through but what we're getting from them
all is a collective sense of war and it
just reminds you of the fact that this
hasn't happened for two years now this
is the first time in a couple of years
because of the pandemic that we've had
the trooping of the color as this public
spectacle and quite clearly for the
people here it hasn't disappointed Sarah
Jane
bye-bye sweetheart bye darling bye
shiggy we could see uh the cross what
have they been saying to you uh today
where have they come from we were
talking to some of the crowds that have
been there since well early hours of
Tuesday morning they've traveled from
Canada or America uh who have you been
meeting
yeah well I caught a couple of the
people in the crowds as well we spoke to
someone who was from China and he was
saying that he had come to at least one
other Royal occasion the diamonds we
believe I think it was we also spoke to
people who came from a bit closer some
some people from Newcastle as well one
of whom have been to the trooping of
trooping the color before and another
person who hadn't uh but said that it
was it was a day that was something that
they were expecting and more they craned
their necks they brought their phones as
well that you could see quite a few
people literally just stopping on the
mall as the fly past happened I came
around Aaron as well took it took a
chance to get a video on his phone as
the Red Arrows flew above our head too
and then it was quite it was quite a
moment so lots of people some from
abroad others from uh from from Britain
as well but all of them taking a chance
to drink in a spectacle that they
haven't haven't had the chance to see in
a couple of years now
yeah it really is unprecedented a once
in a lifetime occasion lots of people
making the trip to London for these four
days of celebrations and of course
people marking the occasion up and down
the UK and across the Commonwealth you
can watch it all unfold live here on Sky
News throughout this bank holiday
Platinum Jubilee weekend
well we are live from Buckingham Palace
today where we have seen some
spectacular pageantry to Mark the
Queen's Platinum Jubilee the long
weekend kicked off with the first
official celebrations for Queen
Elizabeth 70 years on the throne it
began with traditional pomp the trooping
of the color the trooping the color the
military parade that marks the Queen's
official birthday and in the next and
after that we saw the RAF fly past some
70 aircraft involved in that streets
around Buckingham Palace uh absolutely
jam-packed really they're just
dispersing now and moving off a lot of
people taking the chance to have selfies
in front of Buckingham Palace we can
take a closer look now at the spectacle
of the day so far
well thousands lined the Mal and the
surrounding streets to pay tribute to
the queen and enjoy the celebrations
that are going to continue well into
this evening and of course for the next
three days those lining the roots
cheered members of the royal family who
made their way to the trooping the color
ceremony on horse guards parade The
Duchess of Cornwall rode alongside the
Duchess of Cambridge and all three of
her children in the Royal Carriage
Francis George and Louis and Princess
Charlotte for the very first time
our first sighting of the queen was on
the balcony of Buckingham Palace
she looked over the parade below and
received the salute from the soldiers
involved in the trooping the color the
Duke of Kent was at her side
from there she could no doubt hear the
king's troop Royal Horse artery firing
an 82 gun salute from cannons in Hyde
Park in central London
foreign
the big moment the assembled crowd had
all been waiting so patiently for the
queen leading out other members of the
royal family working members of the
royal family uh to loud cheers
and from there they watch an
extraordinary fly past of raw Navy
helicopters and RAF Jets it included
both modern and historic aircraft
including a Spitfire a hurricane and a
Lancaster bomber the Red Arrows also
took part to close out that part of the
festivities uh planes spelled out the
number 70 to Mark the number of years of
the Queen's reign
okay
well there was some disturbance at the
beginning of the tubing ceremony earlier
today the Met police had made a number
of arrests After People breached the
security barrier and tried to enter the
mail earlier on today the police have
said that the arrests were public order
related for Highway obstruction the
Environmental Group animal Rebellion
have claimed that they were behind the
protest
uh let's go from London to Australia
shall we beacons from around the
Commonwealth have been lit to Mark the
occasion Australia among the first to
light a beacon with the country's prime
minister lighting one in Canberra
throughout the UK and the Channel
Islands beacons will be lit this evening
with a queen lighting the principal
Jubilee beacon in a special ceremony
later tonight at Windsor Castle
um well I have joined now uh by uh
former Royal press secretary to the
queen Hello nice to see you afternoon we
are very privileged to have you here a
great Insight that you will have that
you can share with myself Rhiannon and
Dave jarella lovely who are here um
Simon Simon Lewis I should say um what
will be happening uh behind the scenes
today because I think we see a very
public facing Monarch now that they are
in the balcony do as a shop what will be
happening well the first thing the
rehearsals would have been hugely
strenuous getting ready for today
everything has been so precise just the
sheer work that goes into the rehearsals
and the physical effort on the day for
the members of the royal family is just
extraordinary so I suspect it might be
relaxing in there at the moment but
there's a long way to go I mean that's
this is just the start of four days in
which we're recognizing this wonderful
contribution of the queen so I think
they are all ready for four days of
Celebration and uh pacing these events
is so important and I think making sure
the queen in particular is able to sort
of take the rest that she needs to
whilst the others are doing their bit is
also pretty much part of the plan how
mindful are the Palace of getting the
tone right of these Jubilee celebrations
it is of course an historic occasion the
likes of which we will never see in this
country again uh but it comes at a very
difficult time for the country the cost
of living we're just coming out of the
pandemic there's a war in Europe there
is a real sense that the tone has to
reflect that somewhat well I worked at
the palace in the run-up to the golden
jubilee and the Mantra was don't get
expectations ahead of reality and I
think the palace is always so good at
managing expectations so that worked
very well the Diamond Jubilee was just
at the time of the Olympics so managing
that so I think getting the tone right
and just looking out there and seeing
how wonderfully happy people are I think
once again the palace has judged the
tone of this Jubilee absolutely right
I think over the years and and Simon was
alluding to this so you had for example
the Silver Jubilee was 1977 a time of
enormous social change and and also
economic crisis then you had the golden
jubilee that came after a very tricky
decade for the royal family so the death
of Princess Diana for example Diamond
Jubilee yes big celebrations William
mccage just got married we had the
Olympics but also you have to remember
the year before there had been riots in
London and I think that's what the queen
has always done so well is she has she's
adapted and changed but not changed for
change's sake and and that's an
interesting point that the historian
Anthony Selden made to me was that
there's often advisors if you don't mind
and maybe the prime minister or others
who would say well maybe we need to we
need to react now we need to and it's
often from the queen it's been a softly
softly approach but she's always tried
to do the right thing to make sure that
she is reflective with what is happening
around the world and in the country and
the other day I went out to Oxford there
was a team there who was set up during
the pandemic their Street party is all
going to be using food that's been
donated they were making bunting out of
curtains and potato bags that is
happening up and down the country and I
think the royal family of course will
will applaud that yes we look at this
magnificent pageantry but also people
are doing it within their means but it's
all about how can you do it and how can
you just gather as a community and
celebrate in whatever ways you can yeah
members of the royal family are
traveling up and down the UK this
weekend Duchess of Cambridge the
wessexes they're going out to Northern
Ireland Scotland and where to to take
the royal family to all corners of the
UK to reflect that everyone's involved
there's three Royal Riders who are
riding they've got to get back get all
their togs off
their washes get the dogs off clink
Clank in their Spurs and all the stuff
they've got change into other clothes I
hope I have a sandwich I I have a
gorgeous report from one of the um this
was after the coronation when one of the
BBC reporters not a sky reporter because
that didn't exist in those days went
into the Abbey after the queen had been
crowned and they went into the inner
Chambers Behind where they'd made a
table for all the people the Royal
people who had been there and the people
had some little sandwiches and there
were some crumbs and chairs pushed back
empty glasses of champagne and the Royal
reporter Audrey Russell said it on the
footman I think I know where the queen
sat am I right the footman just went and
there was a little Immaculate chair
pushed Niti back into the table there
were no crumbs there the napkin hadn't
been unfolded and the glass of champagne
was still absolutely three quarters full
and I thought that's the queen taking it
seriously all the way through never go
we've done it but absolutely steady
steady as a rock and if they may just
build that I think the absolute
Brilliance of the queen is to have
evolved but not seeming to have changed
I mean 70 years we recognize exactly the
same virtues the same personality as
those who are around some years ago I
just think that's marvelous to be able
to evolve but give that sense of
continuity and those core values that we
all you know respect so much yeah and
Sam is something we haven't mentioned
today is someone who is very much
missing from these celebrations that is
the Duke of Edinburgh Prince Philip and
and Simon it's interesting you were the
communications secretary to the queen
um but an interesting story is that when
you're interviewed for that role he was
alongside her and that illustrates how
they were very much in it together so he
is very much a missing part of this this
wonderful occasion and we remember the
Thames pageant 10 years ago where he
bravely sat through he was not going
there driving rain and I had to say at
the interview he asked most of the
penetrating questions as you would
expect I think he was a brilliant
innovator actually the Duke of Edinburgh
and history is already very kind to him
to give you one example he he realized
that a royal website would be a
brilliant thing to have alongside the
traditional press office and in 1998
when we created it we thought it might
be an interesting sort of Sideshow it's
now hugely popular and the Duke of
Edinburgh kind of had that sense of
being able to think ahead but always on
behalf of the Queen the changes that
have taken place um what do you think
the Queen's picture gallery you could
never have seen those paintings all
those have come down the shop Buckingham
Palace shop and if you go in there you
see gorgeous things copies of the
Queen's jewelry copies of her own
teacups and sauces all her Treasures
been copied we can buy them they're not
very expensive they're beautifully made
when I do overseas trips I always go to
Buckingham Palace shop and get something
that I know or means something in Far
Away lands yeah really really thrilling
I think it's changed so slowly that some
of us haven't even seen the difference
that's taken place over these decades
actually I think she's been she's been
one of those public figures who who now
for everyone isn't it it's whether
you've got your Instagram account it's
whether you've got your Twitter account
it's all about your profile and for the
queen it's it's never been about that
it's never been about the personal
profile or her own her own standing it's
ultimately been about the institution
and doing what's best for the
institution and sometimes that has been
some very difficult decisions so we've
seen that most recently with the likes
of prince Andrew and also the sussexes
as well but I think just yeah as you say
just evolving over time but today we
have seen that culmination again have
those Traditional Values and as he was
saying earlier Britain did its best like
who does it like us nobody it's amazing
I think it's amazing yeah I remember so
just presenting an idea to the queen for
a big event when I was the palace and
took a Majesty through it and there's a
long pause and she said that's far too
grand for us she said so I think that
sense of just being down to earth do say
what it was
did you agree to some of it of course
because the queen is a great pragmatist
yes
um but I think that sense of knowing
actually what the British people want
and what the British people expected is
deep inside her spirit actually I would
have loved to have been uh
education's director that went to the
queen with the story you were telling
about earlier about uh James Bond and
jumping out of a helicopter like how
they got the queen to agree to that I I
don't know the private secretaries and
um and I think David Cameron at the time
might have had a bit of a hand in it I
wonder what their big idea was if that
was the Compromise exactly
and and Simon and we were talking
earlier about obviously this weekend is
all about reflection and thanks for the
Queen's 70 years of service but it's
also a a subtle look ahead to the future
of the monarchy and Rihanna you said
this before you've noticed a subtle
change in Communications from the palace
and events the members of the royal
family that are out there
message will you take from today in
terms of the rules we saw in the balcony
and what's unfolded so far I think it's
quite simple that whatever happens in
the future there will be a smooth
transition I mean what has happened over
the last few years is the Prince of
Wales has taken on more responsibilities
as has Prince William but again it's all
been done seamlessly there's a
commonwealth head of government's
meeting in June uh sorry later this
month the principles will represent the
Queen the investitures I mean I think
it's been handled very carefully in
being realistic but at some stage there
will be a succession but hopefully it's
a long term in the future and when it
does happen people will feel yes there's
been a logic behind it and slowly she's
been delivering those little messages
hasn't she about yes Camilla being Queen
being very supportive of the Prince of
Wales as being a future being head of
the Commonwealth softly softly as you
would with any family don't you think
yes I know you don't have seen that
she's been pushed out because we all see
her as our own mother grandmother great
grandmother we've all we've owned her
most people I'm old enough to have
remembered King George VI because I was
only six when he died but most people
have only ever known the queen so it's a
huge change in people's lives that's all
we've known this sort of this mother
figure literally as I said a mothership
is suddenly not going to be that there
will be somebody there but it won't be
her I think it's going to be a bump and
I think she knew that was going to
happen and so I think she's just making
it smoothie smooth look there's a
picture of her the coronation look at
that this what a day
and we talk about and you're in Malaysia
I was yeah I was in Malaysia and didn't
really know what England was really and
we all called it home but we didn't have
a home here
yeah and she was so
young and glamorous and I think
um what I'm always struck by is in
recent years of course we've gone mad
for
the Duke and Duchess of Cambridge and
the Duke and Duchess of Sussex and
they've been seen as the rock stars of
the Royal Family
go back to the late 1940s and early
1950s
Elizabeth and Philip the world would
come out to see them yeah thousands and
thousands of people would come out to
see them whenever they traveled around
the world and here in this country they
were such a glamorous young couple look
at them they were stunning and some of
their private footage which we've seen
over the week of the queen as a younger
woman so vivacious great sense of humor
having a really good time and obviously
part of what she's done of all these
years is just to marry that with this
commitment to public duty and to service
and it's just it's a great achievement
It's a Wonderful achievement and she's
never said I don't feel like doing it
she might have done
it we'd never know it I think that might
have just been between her and Prince
Philip she has always turned up and
Simon I know you're going to come back
speak to us in the next hour
um Simon Lewis uh former communication
secretary to the queen and Joanna we're
approaching our final couple of minutes
with you because you're leaving us at
two o'clock but you are returning on
Sunday for the big pageant yes yes do
you want to come back for the big pages
foreign
complete mixture eclectic mix of all
kinds of things with Splendor and humor
and right from the earliest we can all
remember right after the present day
celebrating everybody the queen will see
it as celebrating everybody
and we're told that the pageant will
take us through her 70 years decade by
decade which will as we've been just
been watching some of those coronation
pictures it's going to be a trip down
memory lane for so many people for the
younger generation it is it's that they
didn't know as well and we're going to
leave you with some pictures of the
balcony
um appearance of the royal family the
queen we've seen her twice so far today
uh Rihanna when will we see her in
public again remind us so this evening
around 9 30 9 45 where she will like
that Beacon at winds Castle
okay
be live on Sky News with Kay Burley and
with our Royal commentator Alistair
Bruce and Rhiannon as well and we'll be
there you'll be here all weekend camping
out somewhere
um and as we go out Rihanna just remind
us who we saw on the balcony today
so this was the moment that the crowds
really wanted this weekend there is only
one star of this Platinum Jubilee she
may be incredibly modest and want to
make sure that this is a moment that the
whole country can come together and
celebrate those values of service and
duty but ultimately the crowds as they
head down the mountain will be delighted
that they saw the 96 year old Monarch
looking so well enjoying this historic
moment with her family
uh Rihanna Thank You Rihanna is going to
be back with me at two o'clock Simon we
will see you then as well a danger on a
lovely it has been a pleasure we'll see
you on Sunday uh stay with us here on
Sky News
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
it's two o'clock you're watching Sky
News live from Buckingham Palace for
special coverage of an historic moment
the Queen's Platinum Jubilee
the balcony moment cheers for the queen
as she leads out members of the royal
family to watch the celebrations
it included an extraordinary display
from the RAF including typhoons forming
the number 70. in honor of a number of
years of the monastery
[Music]
trooping the color the military parade
to Mark the Queen's official birthday
took place for over two hours
The Duchess of Cornwall arrived in an
open top Carriage alongside the Duchess
of Cambridge and her children princess
George and Louis and Princess Charlotte
there was some disruption police
dragging people out who had jumped the
barriers on the mall the Met later said
arrests have been made
and celebrations will be taking place
across the world Australia's prime
minister among the first to light a
jubilee Beacon at a ceremony in Canberra
[Music]
hello good afternoon live from
Buckingham Palace where today we have
seen some spectacular pageantry to Mark
the Queen's Platinum Jubilee the long
weekend has kicked off with the first
official celebrations for Queen's Queen
Elizabeth 70 years on the throne it
began with traditional pomp the trooping
of the color the trooping the color the
military parade that marks the Queen's
official birthday and an RAF fly past
thousand line the streets around
Buckingham Palace and millions across
the country are hosting Street parties
in the Queen's honor let's take you
through what we have seen so far today
well thousands lined the Mal and the
surrounding streets to pay tribute to
the queen and enjoy the celebrations
which are going to continue into the
evening and of course for the next three
days events began with trooping the
color the military parade marking the
Queen's official birthday more than 1400
parading soldiers 200 horses and 400
musicians came together for this display
which was watched by a crowd that
included the prime minister
those lining the roots cheered as
members of the royal family made their
way to the ceremony on horse guards
parade the gestures of Cornwall rode
alongside the Duchess of Cambridge and
her three children in the Royal Carriage
princess George and Louis and Princess
Charlotte
there was however some disturbance at
the beginning of the ceremony the Met
police now say they've made a number of
arrests After People breached the
security barrier and tried to enter the
Mao police said arrests for public order
related to Highway obstruction have been
made the Environmental Group animal
Rebellion have claimed that they were
behind the protest
on our first sighting of the queen was
on the balcony of Buckingham Palace
where she received the salute from the
soldiers involved in today's parade the
Duke of Kent was at her side
from there she can no doubt here the
king's troop Royal Horse artillery
firing at 82 gun salute from cannons in
Hyde Park Central London
foreign
[Applause]
crowd had all been waiting for the queen
leading out other working members of the
royal family onto the balcony here at
Buckingham Palace to loud cheers
from there they watched an extraordinary
fly past a royal Navy helicopters and
RAF Jets there were both modern and
historic aircraft including a fire a
hurricane and a Lancaster bomber the red
arrows took part they closed off the
spectacle
at typhoons also flew spelling out the
number 70 the number of years
of the monarchs reign
well after the official events Prince
Charles made his way down to the mall to
meet well-wishers who had been Gathering
some of them since the early hours of
Tuesday Morning Sky News did manage to
get a quick sighting of him and he told
us he was quite warm through the
trooping of the color
how was it your Royal Highness how was
it
quite warm
how was it wrong
or just a quick Glimpse here with me our
Royal correspondent Rihanna Mills blink
and you'll miss them um but going off
script yeah I think it's really
interesting and very much in the style
of the Prince of Wales and The Duchess
of Cornwall they cannot resist a crowd
it's a nightmare for their police
officers but they always want to get out
and say thank you and I think that's
what they're all family ultimately
wanted to do is thank all those who've
come out it does look amazing here today
and the crowds have been spectacular
yeah of course Prince Charles referring
to the fact that he was part of tube
being the color alongside their Princess
Anne and Prince William and we were
remarkable remarking how hot it was in
terms of you know with all the uh their
finery on on Horseback and that's what
he was referring to when he said quite
warm I think that was an understatement
us Brits we love to talk about the
weather don't we but yeah it is striking
really that we know that the queen had
decided that the Prince of Wales the
Duke of Cambridge and the princess Royal
would be those who would represent her
ultimately when it came to taking the
salute on horse guards parade and when
you think Prince Charles and Princess
Anne both in their 70s and yet still
there composed on Horseback for for the
whole proceedings yes it's quite a thing
let's talk about the highlights um from
today one of which was seeing uh
princess George and Louis and Princess
Charlotte in their first Royal Carriage
procession quite a moment it was a real
reminder that this is going to be a
weekend where yes we are going to see
the spectacular pageantry the official
events but at the heart of this is also
a family and the family want to come out
to show how much they respect the queen
and celebrate with the rest of us and so
we know that in the past the cambridges
have allowed their children to appear on
the balcony and I think today they
decided was the right moment for them to
to get in the carriages and properly get
waving to the crowds and you can see
that Princess Charlotte and Prince Louis
seem to enjoying the waving slightly
more than Prince George Who seems a
little bit nervous but again I think
it's a reminder that we have that line
of succession don't we and all eyes will
be on Prince George who one day will
have very important responsibilities
lying ahead yeah one incredible thing to
contemplate in your head when you're
only eight years old and that's what we
did see let's talk about what we didn't
see or who we didn't see we did come to
an understanding that we might perhaps
see the Duke and Duchess of Sussex
trooping the color we didn't but they
were here because certain photographers
have managed to get some photographs
especially of Megan within what is
called the major General's office and
this is a balcony area where the royal
family Those whom aren't on Parade as it
were they stand on this balcony and look
out the windows and watch the parade now
I was told by Harry and Megan's team
yesterday that they were very much
looking forward to seeing trooping the
color of course we know that there has
been so much debated discussion about
whether or not they'd be involved in the
proceedings today
um but no it was I think
telling that we didn't see them
necessarily interacting with other
members of royal family but we were
saying it earlier weren't we they would
be damned if they did and damned if they
didn't people would say well if they had
appeared at that window then they were
overshadowing the queen and then of
course others are going to say well why
didn't we see them front and center but
yes they are here and again a reminder
that for the queen she wants her family
around her and despite everything she
has continued to stress they are much
loved members of the family one member
of the family though that we didn't see
was the Duke of York and I think it was
decided that after he was forced to give
up his military titles and step down
from from Royal life that was going to
be a step too far for him to be here
today perhaps my hiss we see him
potentially so tomorrow we've got the
Thanksgiving service for the queen at St
Paul's and I think that is again being
seen as it's a family occasion so I
suspect we'll again see the royal family
there on mass
um it's really difficult to judge of
course we didn't expect him to take
center stage at Prince Phillips Memorial
and he was the one who ultimately walked
in with the queen so to be honest
nothing surprises me at the moment but
again the queen showing that her family
matters and she wants them around her
um
two little people who we haven't seen
and we might not because
um you know that you can judge as a
Sussex are very protective of their two
young children uh Lily Bett the newest
addition to their family turned one this
weekend and as far as we are aware
nobody in the royal family not even the
queen has met young Lilly bet yet we
understand that that obviously will be
happening this weekend but not within
public View
again it's so hard to guess but we
think that the Sussex is again it hasn't
been confirmed to us but we think that
they are staying at Frogmore cottage
which was their family home before they
decided to move to America that of
course is on the Windsor estate we know
that the queen after she has well she's
still in Buckingham Palace because the
state standard is still flying but she
will be heading back to Windsor Castle
and that is where she's going to base
herself for most the weekend so they are
in such close proximity that yeah it
would make sense that
um great granny would meet her namesake
they want to get together they probably
just don't want us watching exactly
um but yeah it's going to be really
interesting to see how much we we do see
Harry and Megan for example there's the
big concert that's here on Saturday
night there's the pageant on Sunday so
there are a number of different
occasions where they won't necessarily
be able to hide within a building
um to watch the spectacle unfold okay
well Rihanna the formal part of the
afternoon is over we have of course got
the Beacon Lighting this evening uh
you've got to go off because you haven't
finished working you've got to go and
make a report for later
and bring us to bring it to us on the TV
a little bit later so we'll let you go
reality and we'll see you later
well thousands of people here uh saw the
parade earlier on today uh thousands of
people lining the route uh Skies Ashner
hurlag uh is on the mount still lots of
people there Ashner soaking up the
atmosphere
Sarah Jane there are so many people here
I mean you could just see that behind me
throngs of people are still streaming up
the mouth this area of course was uh
empty earlier to make room for the
parade to come through and I was lucky
enough to go and see if myself at horse
guards parade but there are so many
people here from all over the world
including a family that I've managed to
get to speak to me hello can I chat to
you about being here where have you
traveled from we've come from Reading
from uh nice and local local it only
took us an hour to get here tell me how
it was seeing it was your favorite bit
it was a it's been fabulous
um we saw the planes going past and the
Red Arrows we were here in 2002 2012 so
I had to come today
um how does this Jubilee compared to the
other ones you've been we were actually
on the mile the previous ones today we
couldn't make it so we were in Trafalgar
Square what was the atmosphere like
really good we had our picnic blankets
out
um had a lovely time for whole family
was there really good atmosphere talk to
me about the what the what the British
monarch means do what does the queen
mean to you and being here and seeing
her what was that like she has sort of
served us all these years there's a huge
contribution there
um so we just had to come out it's been
um yeah a great day uh yeah and what
about you Adam were you excited to be
here do you want to miss it oh
absolutely it was a fantastic experience
and I would have not missed it for
anything I mean this is a once in a
lifetime opportunity I have to say was
it really special getting to see her
because we've heard so much about her
being a bit poorly now and again but she
had such a big smile on her face she was
thrilled was it she is such a great
inspiration
um at her age and how much she's
contributed like she was saying earlier
what a what a great role model for the
British people
is that your daughter over there yeah
yeah yeah hello hello can I chat to you
tell me about what it's been like being
here
um it's really good yeah the atmosphere
being like
um there's a lot of people and it's kind
of hard to get through but it's really
nice I've heard you had a picnic as well
what did you have in your picnic uh we
just had some like
sandwiches and stuff like that oh
amazing and did you get to see the queen
on the balcony with the other members no
are you going to come back for the other
days over the weekend I don't know maybe
you're only local you're only down in
Reading oh thank you so thank you very
much I hope you have a lovely day so
many people here if I grab someone else
hello can I I'll just lie yes absolutely
live now please don't swear for us
yeah what was it like being here it was
absolutely incredible so I'm a massive
lover of the queen so luckily well
unluckily I came to London a bit later
than I should have done so I ended up in
down the street but you know it's part
of the atmosphere part of the vibe I saw
the flyover absolutely amazing we're all
here celebrating the Queen's 70 years on
the rain and I cannot just say what an
amazing atmosphere and it's so lovely
for the people of the UK to come
together show their love and
appreciation for the model key and yeah
what can I say God bless the queen what
did you make of the flyover because I
was down at Green Park and there were so
many people and everyone was just gone I
mean I tried to get up to the Palace not
myself and you know I couldn't get up
here because of obviously the crowd
control I managed to see it from Downing
Street you know I've got a glimpse of it
and that's all I needed at the end of
the day we're all here celebrating her
70 years on the rain so you know it's
the atmosphere that counts it's being up
here you know thank you so much I
appreciate your time thank you there you
go so many people thrilled to be able to
be here I guess it feels like such an
occasion and yeah you're right thousands
of people streaming through the mouth
it's like they're going to be here for a
number of days and some of them have
even bought tents
up the atmosphere on the mall as those
crowds disperse so many people and just
sticking around to soak up the
atmosphere here and I just want to bring
you this that we've had in the last few
minutes it's from the Prime Minister
he's put out a tweet congratulating Her
Majesty the queen on a remarkable
Platinum Jubilee it says a
congratulations the whole country
Commonwealth and world thank you for
your unwavering Duty and service
um vivat Regina Elizabeth God Save the
Queen a bit of Latin there didn't study
that school prime minister uh clearly
did uh here with me now a former Royal
press secretary Simon Lewis Simon good
to see you back again
um excuse my terrible Latin um let us
first start by talking about how you
think the day has gone over all so far
because this really was kicking off what
will be four days of Celebration and
reflection
I think it's been a wonderful day
um it's a bit like the Euros without the
aggression I mean just a number of
people out there the fun the sense that
people are recognizing something
historic the fly pass was fantastic so I
think if I was sitting inside the palace
back in my office now I'd be thinking so
far so good but quite a long way to go
still got a wonderful atmosphere yeah a
lot happening over the next uh three and
a half days now we're halfway through
the first day and I wonder what you
would have made if you were sitting back
in your old Office of the Duke and
Duchess of Cornwall going off script
going rogue deciding that they want to
go on a walkabout on the mound much to
everybody's surprise I'm sure they're a
security team well I think the close
Protection Team might have had a goal
but the interesting thing about
walkabouts is I think members of the
royal family get tremendous energy from
them because if you think about it
you're spending a lot of time in the
back of a car or being transported
events I think the energy particularly
the the Prince of Wales and The Duchess
get from being with people and getting a
sense of the mood is wonderful and I
think that's great I think people really
like that but it probably really does
mean that people have to move quite
quickly yeah to ensure everything is
okay but yeah great great thing to see
yeah hopefully we'll see a lot more of
it I know that members of the royal
family are moving around across the UK
on the Queen's behalf uh this weekend
heading to Scotland Wales and Northern
Ireland and can we talk about the
sussexes because that is a big story
this weekend will we won't we see that
we didn't see them trooping the color we
understand they were their photographers
saw them um but Rhiannon Mills Royal
cross Bond and I were discussing they
found it they do damned if they don't
what do you think we're gonna going to
get this weekend and
what do you think they should do
well I always think of the monarchy as
being the institution and then there's
the family I think the Eternal
fascination with the royal family is
that they are a family and I think in a
way they hold up a mirror to all of us
so all families have ups and downs All
Families have relationships that change
the most important thing is that they're
here to be with the queen during these
next few days as you say and I don't
quite know it's going to pan out but
it's a difficult one but being here I'm
sure think about as a family is the
right thing to do yeah I would imagine
other members of the royal family would
not want to overshadow the queen this
weekend because it is all about her 70
years of service and Duty so I would
imagine that is playing very much on the
social City's mind in terms of they they
have fancy the crowds want to see them
but again it will create headlines that
detract from the Monarch yes and that's
exactly the point this is about the
queen this is about the last 70 years
and everything we've seen so far as you
say is about putting the Queen Center
Stage to the extent that's possible
given the sort of the rest and what she
can do and it's a family and it's a big
family and it's a family with different
relationships and I think that's what
makes it interesting but also has to be
carefully managed yeah they'll all be
having lunch together now won't they
that's what that's where the real
dynamics will come out and that's
understandably behind closed doors
um you were with the queen for the gold
Jubilee 20 years ago
how's the monarchy changed in that time
it doesn't seem like that long ago it
even strikes me when I say 20 years but
how has it changed in that time well as
I was saying earlier it's evolved but
actually it hasn't changed in front of
our eyes I mean one good example is if
you think of 20 years ago the newspapers
that dominated the coverage with the
Tabloid newspapers I mean they were a
royal story was the biggest thing a
tabloid paper could get 20 years on the
internet now five billion users as
opposed to 100 million and knights and I
did that now it's much more significant
so how we think about the royal family
and how they communicate with the media
is one big change secondly families
change as well as I was saying earlier
so during those later years Prince
William and Prince Harry were at school
they were actually away from the cameras
and we've seen them emerge as public
figures in their own right so it's been
handled very subtly but I think what
we've seen is a family change in front
of Verizon institution Buckingham Palace
wasn't open 20 years ago people could
now visit Buckingham Palace
investigators were in films so we look
back and you can see there's been much
more change than they would appear at
the time and that's been the secret and
that continues to be the secret but the
one thing I put my finger on is this
opening up of how people see the
monarchy not just relying on tabloid
newspapers
in a crisis because her 70-year Reign
has not all been smooth sailing and as
her communication secretary I'd imagine
you've had some very difficult very
personal conversations with her what's
she like at that time well first of all
she's had enormous experience the first
Prime Minister was Winston Churchill
she's met all 14 U.S presidents very
cool-headed very pragmatic and also very
importantly for advisors very happy to
take advice and I think that's what you
need in a leader of a nation and someone
who's actually able to display those
qualities in good times and in bad
um Simon Lewis former communication
secretary to the queen thank you so much
for your company this afternoon it's
been fascinating enjoy the rest of the
weekend
I might go and have a drink with some
friends oh nice yes a jubilee pint I
like it very good to see thank you very
much we are watching Sky News live at
Buckingham Palace I'm sure quite a few
people will be joining Simon in raising
a toast to the queen this weekend coming
up I'm going to get the view from Wales
I'll be talking to the first Minister
Mark drayford that's coming up in a few
minutes
[Music]
I'm Dan Whitehead and I'm Sky news's
West of England correspondent
I'm Adam Parsons I'm Sky's Europe
correspondent based here in Brussels
the flares going off a volley of rocks
problems have been pulled up out and are
being used as missiles to help at these
police
we take you to the heart of stories that
shape our world
[Music]
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
we have now left Italy and entered
France nobody's asked to check our
identity
made by people who dare to challenge
nice to see you again Mr Barney
why committing you
fishing does have the potential to
stymie an enormous economic deal
what strikes you when you come to this
Glacier is not just the way in which the
environment is changing but the speed at
which those changes are happening
it's uh devastating actually
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello welcome back to Buckingham Palace
on a day of celebration for the Queen's
Platinum Jubilee over the course of her
Reign the queen has visited every region
of Wales and has spoken of her fondness
for the country's people and its culture
we're joining you now is Mark Drakeford
first minister of Wales first Minister
good to see you this afternoon thank you
for joining us here on Sky News
pleasure good to be with you
talk to me about how whales will be
marking this historic occasion this
weekend
well we've already had a great event
here in a wonderful Democratic space
outside the centers thousands of people
here
gun salute
military bans Male Voice Choir and some
very very excited children
yeah we saw a few of those on the
balcony of Buckingham Palace a short
time ago first Minister
um members of the royal family are
traveling to all parts of the UK to very
much
um make sure that you know this is felt
in every corner of the UK you have the
Duke and Duchess of Cambridge heading
your way this weekend
well people will be looking forward to
that we're very used of course to having
the Prince of Wales here he visits Wales
every year and uh spends time every
summer visiting different parts of Wales
and making sure that Wales is fully
included in the events of this weekend
will be appreciated by uh thousands of
people in every part of Wales
can you talk to us about how close the
bond is between Wales and the monarchy
well shall I simply say this that the
Senate here has been opened now since
1999. we know because of papers that
have been released from the National
Archive that the queen was originally
advised not to come to Wales to open the
First National Assembly uh but she
decided uh quite rightly that this was a
parliament here in Wales she came to
that first opening and she's never
missed one since and even in this last
year which we know has had its
challenges uh in health terms she was
here at the official opening of the
seneth meeting people delivering the
opening address and I think that that
history that history of the connection
between the queen and that very new
Democratic Forum that we have here in
Wales tells us a great deal about the
commitment of The Sovereign to Wales and
the appreciation that is felt for her
here
very much so and
talk to me about the Beacon Lighting
this evening uh
that's happening in Wales it's happening
across the UK and across the
Commonwealth as well
over 2 000 beacons are being lit across
the United Kingdom and over a hundred of
those will be here
in Wales there's a long tradition of
lighting beacons in Wales uh in terms of
and Times of danger and at times of
Celebration as well and there'll be a
network of these beacons where in some
parts of Wales you'll be able to see one
from the next
uh as the sun goes down on what is at
the moment a thoroughly beautiful
summer's day here in Wales uh that will
be a spectacular sight and we'll draw
today's the first day of the
celebrations to a memorable close
I'm glad the sun is shining in Wales
let's hope it lasts all weekend Mark
Drakeford first Minister giving us the
view from Wales of of how the country is
marking this very special Platinum
Jubilee we appreciate your time this
afternoon here on Sky News thank you
well it is sunny in Wales it is sunny
here in London let's take a look at the
weather for the rest of the UK
warm memories wherever you go
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
well the good news is the high pressure
is returning to settle the weather for
this Jubilee weekend Southern parts are
going to be dry and clear for today
plenty of sunshine elsewhere as well
however Cloud will bubble up through the
day with showers breaking out over
Scotland and Northern England Ireland is
going to be mostly cloudy a few
outbreaks of rain there they may turn
heavy at times the wet weather is going
to Edge eastwards throughout this
afternoon with showers following into
the Far West there'll be some isolated
showers over parts of Wales and the
north west but it is going to be sunny
and warm elsewhere with light winds
temperatures will reach a maximum of 23
degrees Celsius that's 73 Fahrenheit
overnight rain will cross the Irish sea
spreading into Northwestern England
Southern Scotland and Wales for a time
it's going to be a dry night elsewhere
and milder then last night with
temperatures widely holding onto those
double figures showery rain in the west
will retreat tomorrow with Friday likely
to be the warmest day of this bank
holiday weekend
temperatures could reach 25 degrees
Celsius in the southeast
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
you're watching Sky News live at
Buckingham Palace today coming up
our celebrations continue around the
world marking the Queen's 70-year Reign
we'll be taking a look at some of the
numbers that make up those seven decades
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
please turn on
hello welcome back to Sky News live from
Buckingham Palace this afternoon we have
seen some spectacular pageantry today to
Mark the Queen's Platinum Jubilee the
long weekend has kicked off with the
first official celebrations for Queen
Elizabeth's 70 years on the throne it
began with traditional pomp the trooping
the color the military parade that marks
the Queen's official birthday and there
was an RAF fly past thousands of people
lining the streets around Buckingham
Palace and millions across the country
have been hosting Street parties in the
Queen's honor Julie celebrations are
taking place across the UK and around
the world including the 14 commonwealth
countries the queen is Monarch 2. well
to discuss that and so much more joining
me now broadcaster and Royal commentator
at Wesley curve Wesley good to see you
this afternoon thank you for coming to
see us and proudly supporting your Obe
which you were just telling me in the ad
break that you only wear on uncertain
occasions only work for trooping the
color and for the Commonwealth day
service at Westminster Abbey but Majesty
gave it to me seven years ago for
services to Heritage but I but I'm also
a journalist and really followed her and
the family all my life but really for
the last 30 40 years
in in my journalistic work and I think I
think I don't think any of us who were
here today will ever forget it
because trooping has always rather
special but it should almost become
routine sort of before covered and it
was just there's the queen and she's in
the carriage and there's the Duke and it
seems almost took it for granted
something that we took for granted but
but for the first time and I as far as I
can remember the Royal Parts actually
today had to close the park as early as
Court quarter past ten the crowds were
so massive so so I think must have been
hundreds of thousands of people trying
to get in I suppose to see her so there
was all this cacophony and spectacle
but at the heart of it
an amazing woman
and her family so you kind of see I
think the continuity of the institution
it's an institution that would change
both here and abroad but we saw it at
its best today and that's going to
continue over the weekend yeah Wesley
talk to me
I will be
celebrated in Commonwealth Nations this
weekend it'll be interesting to see and
I think it will vary in different places
so I think there will be official
celebrations as there always Are For Her
Majesty's birthday and I think they're
bonfires in all the countries but I
think I think it'll vary because it
people must make a distinction between
the Realms the 14 other Realms and the
commonwealth countries it's worth
remembering there are 54 commonwealth
countries so even though the Jamaican
prime minister has raised the question
of whether they will keep
um the queen as queen Jamaica will stay
in the Commonwealth and in fact Barnes
Scotland is being challenged by the
Jamaican foreign minister to be the
Secretary General of the Commonwealth so
I think that I don't think the monarchy
is particularly fast or feels that it's
a central question whether the Monarch
stays monarch of all these other
countries it's up to these other
countries where um but it served them
well and it's remarkable that this far
in the rain so 45 countries have become
independent Plus in her Reign many of
those have kept the monarchy many
haven't but the Commonwealth I think
still is an entity that means something
in terms of people doing things together
and the common Heritage the common law
the common language the trade links and
that has been one of her great
achievements the shift from Empire to
Commonwealth and the effect that that's
had here on on race relations I think
that she's been a real Pioneer she
re-badged the Commonwealth from 1953 in
a famous speech she made from Auckland
saying it was unlike the empires of the
past that it was a free association
whatever people's Creed or color or
religion and I think and I think that's
I think that's been a light motif of her
reign as has been to try it we must
treat everybody equally and I think that
that's the best of the Commonwealth so
when the Commonwealth was fighting a
part eight partly under her leadership
so I think the Commonwealth has a future
but the role of the monarchy in the
Commonwealth will evolve
um Wesley you followed the queen for a
number of years in in your role as a
journalist and you've been here for many
key moments we were talking again during
the break about how you were here after
the death of Princess Diana and the
Queen's car stopped and totally
unexpectedly she got out to look at
flowers and and you were here for that
you've been on a tour of the Caribbean
with a queen you've had many um
personal moments with her in that
respect what Insight can you give her
into the the queen as a as a woman I
think that what and maybe we're seeing
it more I think one of senior Corsair
from the 90s said she's so relaxed as a
person
so I think in the 80s and 90s people
respected the queen maybe they didn't
University love her they loved the queen
mother and I think in the last 20 years
that kind of universal love that most
people have from the queen as an
individual whatever their feelings about
the institution so you see her
displaying warmth much more I mean the
scenes on the balcony with her and Louis
and Charles the generations and the way
she was just like chatting to the
grandchildren and not necessarily
standing to attention during the
national anthem match you couldn't hear
the national anthem there was so much
Applause so I think that she's always
been extremely dignified head of state
but we see more of the personal side of
her and that's always been there for
those of us that lucky enough to meet
her those sparkling blue eyes the the
perfect skin and the real interest in
you as a person and so I think it's it's
great that we're seeing more of this
towards the end of the rain
because I think she regards herself as
our servant she really doesn't think
that she's better than us that and I
think the light Motif throughout the
last 70 years has been service and I
think today yes there was spectacle but
there was the warmth of a family and a
remarkable human being at the center of
it Wesley it's been a pleasure to talk
to you Wesley Carr thank you so much for
coming to speak to us here on Sky News
um enjoy the rest of the weekend
now leaders from around the world have
been wishing the queen well for her
Jubilee celebration so let's start with
President Biden he released this message
on social media earlier on today
your majesty congratulations on your
platinum Jubilee
for 70 years you've inspired people with
your selfless devotion and service to
the people of the United Kingdom and The
Commonwealth and throughout your Reign
the relationship between the United
Kingdom and the United States has grown
stronger and closer than ever
throughout the years the joy your visits
to the United States have brought
Americans and your solidarity with the
American people in times of tragedy have
deepened the friendship and profound
connection between our countries
and Joe and I were so touched by the
generosity and welcome you showed us
when we visited you at Windsor Castle
last year during our first visit
overseas as president and first lady on
behalf of the people of the United
States we send you our best wishes to
you and the people around the world
marking this momentous and historic
occasion
congratulations to your majesty and have
a wonderful Platinum Jubilee celebration
in a statement on social media the
French President Emmanuel macron
reminisced about his country's
connection with the Royal Family
madame
during the past 70 years the president
of the French Republic has relied on
very few constants at the international
level
times have changed Europe has evolved
our continent is again experiencing War
throughout these Transformations your
Devotion to our alliance and to our
friendship hath remained and has helped
build the trust that brought freedom and
prosperity to our continent since your
first state visit to France when you
were welcome to Paris by a generation
who alongside your Army Navy and Air
Force had fought for the freedom we now
enjoy you have visited us many times
you have shared our Joys and seen the
Deep affection and admiration that the
people of France have for you you have
also visited the graves where so many of
your young men lie and seeing the
respect and honor we constantly pay to
those who sent from your homes to
protect ours
you ask a golden thread that binds our
two countries the proof of the
unwavering friendship between our
Nations your first toast to one of my
predecessors
reminded us that trust and understanding
should endure forever
your words were matched by a lifetime of
Devotion to our alliance
from the dark days when your family
welcomed General the girl in your home
to his joy to welcome you in ease you
have been a constant presence and a
source of wisdom
for the leaders of our two countries
this year the 70s of your Reign we
celebrate your achievements we are
grateful for your courage and we share
the respect and love that the British
people and commonwealths have always
shown you
I want to take a look at some of the
Queen's Milestones now
this year she became the world's third
longest reigning monarch in history
over her 70 years of service the queen
has been served by 14 prime ministers
the first Winston Churchill
there have also been 14 U.S presidents
during her reign with the exception of
one president Lyndon B Johnson she has
met all of them
the queen has been on 271 foreign trips
visiting over 100 countries as molec
she's only missed one that Christmas
broadcast that was uh she's only missed
one that Chris has broadcast during her
seven decades on the throne
and she is known for her love of corgis
the queen has owned more than 30 dogs
most of them descending from her first
Corgi gifted to her on her 18th birthday
in 1944.
well it's an illustration of just how
much things have changed in Northern
Ireland that Michelle O'Neill the Irish
nationalist first Minister designate has
congratulated the queen on her Platinum
Jubilee and now in a rare interview Lord
brookebra of County fermana a personal
friend of her majesty has been telling
Sky News of her contribution to British
Irish relations our senior Island
correspondent David Blevins has this
report
winning hearts for seven decades this
was the then princess Elizabeth's first
visit to enniskillum a time to which she
would return and become a peacemaker
just by crossing the street from the
Protestant Cathedral to the Roman
Catholic one
this when she crossed the street was a
turning point for all the people of the
town and the county it seriously made it
acceptable for both communities to go
into each other's churches
they kind of Broadwater is Lord
Lieutenant of County for mana and a
close friend of the queen is it possible
to add caption it really in a sentence
or two what it is about the queen that
makes her so endearing to people who
don't expect to find her that way when
she meets somebody she talks to them on
a totally even level and she engages she
gets them to engage with her and to be
honest one of one of the uh one of the
reasons is that she's not a terribly
tall person
so she doesn't speak down to people she
always has that twinkle in her eye and a
little smile
and that smile extended to Martin
McGinnis a former Ira Commander the two
shook hands not once but several times
are you well thank you very much I'm
still alive nice to see you again
the first Minister designate an Irish
nationalist has sent Jubilee greetings I
know there are many people that will
hold Queen Elizabeth with high regard
many people will look towards her as
their Monarch and I think that it's
really really important then that I
reflect that and acknowledge that her
Jubilee celebration is an important time
for many many people not least for
herself and I do I do have to also I
think understand that whenever you have
public office for 70 years that's a big
big achievement her historic State visit
to Ireland was a game changer the queen
even speaking in Irish to acknowledge
the president and then dinner guests as
friends
our children
Argus arcoiza
it transformed anglo-irish relations
Lord brookpro recalling the response of
an Irish passenger seated next to him on
a plane he said well you know
uh previously
she was
their Queen
she is now our Queen
Elizabeth II was first to recognize that
Northern Ireland's past need not be its
future
David Blevins Sky News in Belfast
Sky News live at Bucky and Palace coming
up the break
a day of celebration for the queen and
the royal family and also a day of
cultural significance we'll be speaking
to the culture secretary Nadine Doris
about it all
[Music]
we've got two celebration cruises we've
got a champagne afternoon tea and in the
evening we've got a Gala dinner where
you can sail along the river tomes at
night which is a totally different
experience to seeing it during the day
and you'll enjoy a four course meal
you'll also have a live musician and
there's a toast to her majesty at nine
o'clock over the last two weeks we've
seen a lot of interest in it in our in
our Jubilee cruises this has come mainly
from londoners and other people in the
UK and now as people start arriving here
in London from overseas particularly the
U.S market we're seeing some interest
from International visitors I will be
here working working well and hopefully
entertaining the guests a little bit
looking after them and making sure they
enjoy their Journey along the River
Thames which has got 2 000 years of
liquid history and you'll sail up to
yourself lost three historical World
historical flight uh three World
historical sites and enjoy the sights
and landmarks of London
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to Sky News today's parade
here at Buckingham Palace is the first
in a four day weekend of plan events to
celebrate the Queen's Platinum Jubilee
millions of people in the UK and in fact
across the globe are marking a moment of
Real historic and also cultural
significance
joining me now uh culture secretary
Nadine Doris and good to see you
um well I we're halfway through day one
we've got plenty more to come
talk to me about globally how this
weekend is being seen in terms of
cultural significance well it's a a huge
event it marks 70 years of the longest
serving Monarch on the British throne
you know she's taken us through picked
us up after the second world war through
Wars in Iraq the Falklands Afghanistan a
covet pandemic and I think globally
people recognize respect and love that
about our queen that she's been our
strength and stay throughout those 70
years I think we have 1.6 billion
viewers watching the events over the
weekend and and I I think we all know
why this is what we do well in the UK
we've got a monarch that the world
respects and loves and and we know how
to to put on a big event and I think
people are watching because of their
love for the queen and they want to see
what we do in the UK in order to
celebrate and honor that and recognize
it yeah how important is it in terms of
the Commonwealth and I was talking
talking to one of the organizers of the
Commonwealth Games of course Birmingham
in just a few weeks time that's a fast
approaching in terms of the Commonwealth
obviously there are celebrations taking
there as well it really is
coming coming together not just the UK
but Commonwealth Nations and Realms as
well yeah it's it's communities across
the globe it's from you know communities
within the UK Street by Street which has
found out across the world across the
commonwealth countries and across the
Commonwealth Nation but the entire Globe
you know I think we have more countries
wanting to be part of the Commonwealth
now than than ever before so it's it's
what is happening now over these four
days I think is as I've said it's a
celebration it's something's a time to
honor and to Mark the 70 years of the
queen on the throne and it's also
something that 1.6 billion people
worldwide are joining on two yeah there
are so many incredible and many of them
are here actually yes I mean London is
absolutely packed yeah it really is a
focal point for the celebrations as you
said being beamed out across the globe
and so many parties taking place up and
down the country as well over the course
of the weekend and and talking of stats
there are quite a few coming out about
this weekend and one of them is that you
know she has been here for 14 prime
ministers um have you ever had an
audience with a queen have you been in a
fight what was that experience like
because we're talking to so many people
sharing their experiences of them
so I'm a privy counselor so I was sworn
to privy Council by the queen and have
met with the Queen's sense and her wit
her humor her sharpness her intellect
um all of those things
um are humility I think the last time
um I had an audience with his Queen was
by a zoom from a sitting room in in
Windsor all of those things just take
you aback really when you leave having
been in the presence of the queen in awe
of the queen
uh we were back together on Joanna
Lumley was here with us and we were
reflecting about
strong female leader a strong female
figurehead and you know that started
back in her early 20s in the 50s when
you know women weren't taking leading
roles in culture and here she was in her
early 20s and to have sustained that for
70 years
as a woman that that really means
something I think yeah and I think we
can see the the queen that we have today
how she's grown into that position
because she's she will have had to have
dealt with the many suits all of those
years ago and come through to where she
is today and I I think we can see the
person she is today through watches have
been through over those 70 years and in
terms of the royal family and the queen
in particular
it is a brand if you like it's probably
quite crass to say it like that but in
terms of globally how they are
recognized and you know in your role as
culture secretary you you must see that
in terms of how they sell the UK to the
world well they work so incredibly hard
you know the world really looked to us
look to our royal family and and they
think we have something quite amazing
and quite special and we do and it is
quite unique the royal family are you
know is that unique amongst all nations
and their their own royal families and
and they work so incredibly hard to
represent the worlds to the UK to the
world and to represent us so so I
wouldn't call them a brand I think they
call themselves a firm
um but it's as a much better way of
putting it yes but they most definitely
do they are hard-working they are loyal
to the queen they're loyal to the nation
and they work their their sense of
public service is something to behold
and they show that daily in the hours
and the works and the sacrifices that
they make to be a part of the royal
family and and just in terms of the
celebrations this weekend it was a
celebration for many people but others
you know a thank you for service and
Duty for 70 years but then on the other
side of that a lot of people will look
at this and the times we're living in as
you know only too well you deal with it
day in day out cost of living crisis war
in Europe we're still in a pandemic
is the tone being set is the tone being
got right so far in terms of the
backdrop so I I hear what you're saying
but I think post pandemic and post a
terrible two years that people have been
through I think people want to celebrate
I think they want to come together you
know we're one of the few countries in
the world
um but has absolutely no restrictions
whatsoever and people can go out and
celebrate together they can enjoy this
bank holiday weekend and by the way a an
extended four-day bank holiday weekend I
think people want to celebrate they want
to enjoy that they want to take
advantage of what is good weather at the
moment they want they want to come
together and I think we've seen over
recent months almost a yearning for
people you know our theaters are full of
game you know or people are going out
and enjoying life I think they want to
do that and I don't I think the tone is
absolutely right celebrate Rejoice show
your love and respect to the queen I
think that Tone's absolutely right okay
Nadine thank you Nadine Doris culture
secretary really appreciate your time
and you're here for the concert and here
all the way through yeah lovely okay
enjoy it thank you so much Nadine Doris
there culture secretary well a day of
Pomp and padettry here at Buckingham
Palace to celebrate this Platinum
Jubilee it's been quite a show uh we're
gonna bring you some of the highlights
now
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
it is three o'clock you're watching Sky
News live from Buckingham Palace for
special coverage of an historic moment
the Queen's Platinum Jubilee
[Applause]
the balcony moment cheers for the queen
as she leaves out members of the royal
family to watch today's celebrations
an extraordinary display from the RAF
including typhoons forming the number 70
in honor of the years of the Monarch's
reign
[Music]
trooping the color the military parade
to Mark the Queen's official birthday
took place for over two hours
The Duchess of Cornwall arrived at an
open top Carriage alongside the Duchess
of Cambridge and her three children
princess George and Louis and Princess
Charlotte
there was some disruption police
dragging people who had jumped the
barriers on the Mel the Metropolitan
Police later saying arrests have been
made
and there have been celebrations across
the world Australia's prime minister
among the very first to light a jubilee
Beacon at a ceremony in Canberra
[Music]
hello a very good afternoon to you live
from Buckingham Palace where we have
seen some spectacular pageantry today to
Mark the Queen's Platinum Jubilee this
long weekend has kicked off with the
first official celebrations for Queen
Elizabeth's 70 years as Monarch it began
with traditional pomp the trooping of
the color the military parade that marks
the Queen's official birthday and there
was an RAF fly past thousands have lined
the streets around Buckingham Palace and
millions across the country have been
hosting Street parties in the Queen's
honor let's take you through what we
have seen so far
thousands of people lining the Mal and
the surrounding streets to pay tribute
to the queen and enjoy the celebrations
which will continue into this evening
and of course for the next three days
events began with trooping the color of
the military parade that marks the
Queen's official birthday more than 1400
parading soldiers 200 horses and 400
musicians came together for this display
which was watched by a crowd that
included the prime minister
the route
cheered as members of the royal family
made their way to the ceremony on horse
guards parade
The Duchess of Cornwall riding alongside
the Duchess of Cambridge and all three
of her children in the Royal carriage
for the first time
as I mentioned some disruption
the Met police making a number of
arrests After People breached the
security barrier
and tried to disrupt the parade the
police said the arrest were made for
public order related offenses for
Highway obstruction
the Environmental Group animal Rebellion
have claimed they were behind the
protest
well our first sighting of the queen
today was on the balcony of Buckingham
Palace she received the salute from the
soldiers involved in the parade the Duke
of Kent was at her side
from there she could no doubt hear the
king's troop Royal halts artillery
firing an 82 gun salute from cannons in
Hyde Park in central London
foreign
then came the moment everyone had been
waiting for the queen leading out other
working members of the royal family onto
the balcony they were greeted by loud
cheers
from there they watched Alex jewelry fly
past of Royal Navy helicopters and RAF
Jets there was both modern
and there were both modern and historic
aircraft taking place
taking part A Spitfire a hurricane and a
Lancaster bomber the Red Arrows closed
out that spectacle 15 typhoons spelled
out the number 70 to Mark the number of
years of the Queen's reign
just pop my teeth back in sorry about
that well after the official events
Prince Charles made his way down to the
mall to meet well wishes we did manage
to catch a quick sighting of him and he
told us that trooping the color was
quite warm
how was it your Royal Highness how was
it
quite warm
how was it
enjoy the stuff
well let's go to the mouth thousands
there watching the parade uh Skies
Ashner hernak has been down there
talking to them soaking up the
atmosphere Asha there are still quite a
few people hanging around even though
the official part of the day is over
there really is SJ it's streaming full
of people so many people soaked up the
atmosphere as you say so many families
as well really Keen to chat to us I
guess they're just so happy to be here
if we slowly try and cross the threshold
and find this family here hello
Christine tell us about being here what
does it mean to you oh it's really
exciting I'm not um especially a
royalist myself but it's lovely to see
the country together people from lots of
different backgrounds and ages and it's
just been a really nice atmosphere
there's such a buzz in the air isn't it
what do you think it is about the queen
in particular that people really love I
think people respect her age and the
fact that she's got such a commitment to
duty
did you manage to catch a glimpse of
them on the balcony or any of the fly
Parks no we saw the fly pass which was
fantastic it was really exciting it was
brilliant to see are you going to be
making any plans over the next few days
a street party or anything like that on
Sunday
um possibly a street party or a barbecue
something like that we'll enjoy the bank
holiday
much do you think people need something
to celebrate considering the past two
years we've had I think after covid
knowing the sort of international events
that are happening it's really important
to have things that bring us together
and make us celebrate what unites us not
just what divides us very well and did
you have anything in your picnic basket
today some very homemade sandwiches
delicious so very British I love that oh
thank you very much
hello do you want to say hello no shy
little Zach I won't put a camera in his
face so thank you very much hello can I
stop you hiya hi we're on Sky News
yes please what's it like for you being
here today what's it been like today
um well I love it I don't actually live
in London so I'm really happy to be here
today with my sister she's here John and
we've got matching t-shirts as well
we've got a sister as well do you want
to come in come in what both your names
Poppy and Ella lovely sneaky Poppy and
Ella so tell us what did you manage to
see them on the balcony did you manage
to see any of the celebrations today
watched it on TV this morning
yeah just to come down and see what was
happening it's so nice so many people
it's lovely it's a great celebration
it's really there's a buzz in the air
isn't it so I was just talking to
Christine about how um how much does it
mean to you I guess to see the queen 70
years as Queen
um and still going strong it's amazing I
think after everything we've been
through as a country in terms of covert
it's lovely to see everyone getting
together and as a country as well hope
you and Ella enjoy your day thank you
very much should we go and try and find
somebody else SJ should we go should we
go on a little like hello we're live on
Sky News do you want to chat to us hello
no no no one we had loads earlier one
second there's a lady here with a dog
hello oh yeah can I chat to you about
being here oh it's amazing it's lovely
yeah you can also talk about your dog
who's just gorgeous yeah and how's he
doing with all the crowns he's he's
enjoying I think he's enjoying his walks
and all and is she sorry and have you
managed to see the queen today on the
balcony the fly past any of that you
know I wish we could but you're here to
soak up the atmosphere
sorry here to soak up the atmosphere
yeah what does it mean to you to be here
how exciting is it it is really exciting
and yeah we're all happy to be here yeah
you say you all love the queen yes she's
a symbol of unity and she's a symbol of
the nation we absolutely adore it
foreign
and join the celebrations again thank
you thank you so much thank you enjoy
the day well there you go people from
all over the UK but also all over the
world SJ I know my colleague shingy was
talking to someone from China this
morning Kay this morning met somebody
from Colombia I think they said they
were from just goes to show that she
does have that huge International reach
lots of people here from the
commonwealth countries too yet to meet
many of those people but we know there
are we've seen a few flags being waved
about plenty of Canadians too and we
also know there are some Canadians that
have been camping out in the tents
behind me but really there is a huge
celebratory atmosphere for this moment
in history
Ashley thank you I've got Canadian
extended family and they've been
instagramming me with excitement I can
tell you that I've also had people get
in touch from Australia who are watching
us on skynees on the internet hello to
everyone watching in Australia uh
joining me now former director of
communications for the queen Simon Lewis
and Simon we were just commenting there
um on uh the scenes on the mail that
Ashley was part of and the diversity of
people there soaking up the atmosphere
today the different age range they've
come from all over the world to be part
of today and it's quite interesting when
we keep hearing or is it it's a
generational thing the younger
generation aren't really that bothered
about the monarchy I think that might
speak a little differently yes I think
those wonderful images say a lot about
the enduring popularity of the monarchy
and it's funny when I was at the palace
we used to look at the opinion polls
around the popularity of the monarchy
and you know by and large 70 of people
favor the monarchy by and large 20 and
didn't want to monarchy if there was
ever referendum but the interesting
thing is those numbers never change and
the last one I saw the numbers were the
same so I think what the monarchy is
able to do is to reach out to different
demographics those youngsters who are
there today they will no doubt continue
to be great fans of the monarchy I know
the royal family never take that for
granted but having that enduring
popularity not just with young people
the older people but as you say across
the ethnicity of this country is a very
powerful Bedrock for the monarchism
institution
um
you were imposed for the
um the golden jubilee 20 years ago how
do you think the monarchies changed in
that time because just in terms of how
the family looks the events that they've
been through for those past 20 years
there's been a lot of shift how have
they come out the other side to this
Platinum Jubilee in your opinion well
firstly the family has changed 20 years
ago the young princes were very young
and were about to go to or just starting
at school they were out on public eye
now they are in very much in the public
eye the Duke of Edinburgh was Center
Stage so we've seen a family as all
families do change over that period I
think the biggest single change is that
there's been a greater openness I think
the royal family and the monarchies
wanted to reach out more and explain its
purpose explain what it does get people
to understand all the work that goes on
we saw this out this morning those
Charities out there Charities the queen
is either patron of other members of the
royal family so explaining that the
monarchy isn't just about a big Palace
at the end of the mail it's about
delivering service and delivering
benefits for the country yeah they very
much want to make these celebrations
accessible we know about the street
parties that will be taking place up and
down the UK over the course of the
weekend the crowd assembled here for the
trooping the color war from as you
mentioned Charities the Queen's been
associated with former members of the
Armed Forces so she's very much tried to
make it an extended family feel by
including everyone and the Prime
Minister was at the tree pink the color
today
um along you know with various other
dignitaries connected to defense and the
Armed Forces can we talk about the
Constitutional element of the monarchy
and and the Queen's role we mentioned
earlier on that she's seen 14 different
Prime Ministers starting of course with
perhaps one of the most famous Winston
Churchill
well the queen is head of state and we
have a constitutional monarchy so the
Queen's role is extremely important I
think we see that most closely when
there's a change of government I was
working at number 10 when the coalition
government in 2010 was formed and it's
really important that the queen has a
prime minister so part of the driving
force behind the Coalition happening was
to make sure the queen had a prime
minister and it's not just a nicety it's
at the center of the Constitution every
week the Prime Minister goes to meet the
queen either a Buckingham Palace or has
a caller those aren't just going through
the motions that's the a very private
and very important discussion between
the two of them and as you say started
with Winston Churchill there have been
13 prime ministers since right after
Boris Johnson and the other thing is if
you work in the palace or number 10 you
see the red boxes coming in and out of
both places and those red boxes have
papers in there that have to approve by
the queen or the primers or both so
behind the scenes the Constitution works
extremely well but it relies on an
apolitical head of state can you give me
an idea of how busy the queen is in
terms of obviously we talk about public
engagements and she's very much scaled
back on that in recent years
um but what goes on behind the scenes
you talk about those red boxes of course
she sends letters you know talk to me
about her day-to-day duties well there's
a great team at Buckingham Palace that
supports the Queen the private
secretaries who are her constitutional
advisors there are ladies and waiting
there are Clarks so I think the whole
machine of the palace is incredibly
efficient and Incredibly well organized
But ultimately it requires the queen to
also do her job and she does that and
obviously as you say over the years
she's doing Less in public but it
doesn't stop the red boxes coming in so
the Queens we've talked about this
earlier in the day her Devotion to
public duty is at the center of how she
sees her role and I can't be hugely
fascinated in reading all those red
boxes but they still have to be done
yeah and she has a team around it but as
you said she needs to be involved of
everything it literally needs the seal
of approval and Simon saying thank you
we'll talk to you later on Simon Lewis
their former Communications secretary to
the queen let's talk about the new
official photograph that was released
earlier on today of the queen to mark
this Platinum Jubilee what a wonderful
image this is this portrait was taken in
the Victoria vestibule in the Queen's
private apartments at Windsor Castle
earlier on this year it was by the
photographer Ronald
but Kelly who has taken two previous
portraits of the queen alongside the
Prince of Wales and Prince George to
Mark her 90th birthday that was back in
2016 that portrait released earlier on
today well it was released alongside a
jubilee message to the UK and the
Commonwealth I said thank you to
everyone who has been involved in
convening communities families neighbors
and friends to mark my Platinum Jubilee
in the UK and across the Commonwealth I
know that many happy memories will be
created as these festive at these
festive occasions I continue to be
inspired by the Goodwill showed to me
and I hope that the coming days will
provide an opportunity to reflect on all
that has been achieved during the last
70 years as we look to the future with
confidence and enthusiasm
huh well more celebrations uh later on
today a major feature will be the
lighting of the Jubilee beacons now
beacons have long been used to Mark
Royal events like weddings jubilees and
coronations today more than 3 000 of
them are going to be lit across the
British Isles and overseas territories
and across all 54 commonwealth countries
and their capitals the fires will be
ignited at Key historical locations
including the Tower of London
many of the royal residences like
Sandringham and Balmoral
and 40 beacons will be lit along
Hadrian's Wall
also forming a chain of light Coast to
Coast
the queen will make an extra Jubilee
appearance at Windsor Castle today there
she will trigger the lighting of the
principal Jubilee Beacon at Buckingham
Palace
they're a sculpture called the tree of
trees will be part of an immense
lighting installation and the queen will
be represented by the Duke of Cambridge
that's all coming up later on today you
can of course see it live here on Sky
News but right now let's take you live
to Hexum in Northumberland where the
town crier has read out a proclamation
written for the Jubilee Gerard Tom
is there for us Gerard
yep we were here to uh to watch and
record the town crier Joe Mills just
started uh the job here as town crier in
hexham last month uh read out this
Proclamation and it's the same
Proclamation for these beacons being
letters you say across the country and
across the world tonight uh and this is
what he had to say and what also was
said elsewhere across the world
we are celebrating our glorious Queens
Platinum Jubilee
Elizabeth the second of that name
our most beloved Sovereign and head of
the Commonwealth for 70 years
and uh that Proclamation went on
basically to uh say that these beacons
were going to be lit tonight at 9 45 is
the time when the beacons are going to
be lit this is Pomp and ceremony being
taken out to the people and very
deliberately you know the idea of a town
crier being dressed up in quasi-royal
Livery and reading out a proclamation on
behalf of the queen and goes back to
George III the uh The Sovereign who
invented the idea of taking uh the
monarchy out to the country to the north
of England believe it or not George the
first and George II who obviously
preceded George III never even bothered
coming to the north of England during
their entire Reigns or indeed to Wales
or to Scotland or to the Midlands it was
George III who brought the monarchy to
the people and invented uh the the way
that the monarchy works now and a key
part of it is a Pomp and ceremony to be
out in all parts of the country and so
these beacons are being it as you said
they only go back and this is evidence
really that anything that we see as
tradition has to be invented the
lighting of beacons for a royal occasion
only goes back to Queen Victoria's
Diamond Jubilee in 1897 so only 125
years old 125 years sounds a long time
until you realize of course that Queen
Elizabeth II has been on the throne for
70. so not even two Queen Elizabeth's
Reigns before we first had beacons lit
for a royal celebration but they have
been used many times for her majesty and
they will be used tonight and we will be
bringing you the lighting of those
beacons on Sky News of course later on
this evening there'll be big events in
many towns there'll be one here on top
of the moot Hall next to me built in the
Middle Ages here in hexham they're going
to have a beacon here and along
Hadrian's Wall we're hoping to bring you
some pretty spectacular pictures of that
later
yeah it's going to be quite the light
show isn't it um Gerard thank you Gerald
Tubb in hexham Forest uh we're gonna
have cameras right across the country
seeing all of those beacons being lit
live we have a special show for you it
is called the beacon show you can see it
this evening from nine o'clock right
here on Sky News
now leaders from around the world have
been wishing the queen well for her
Jubilee Boris Johnson thanked her in a
message on Twitter earlier today this is
what the Prime Minister said
congratulations to her majesty the queen
on your remarkable Platinum Jubilee the
whole country Commonwealth and world
thank you for your unwavering Duty and
Service vivat Regina Elizabeth God Save
the Queen
President Biden released a video message
that was on social media as well earlier
this afternoon
your majesty congratulations on your
platinum Jubilee
for 70 years you've inspired people with
your selfless devotion and service to
the people of the United Kingdom and The
Commonwealth throughout your Reign the
relationship between the United Kingdom
and the United States has grown stronger
and closer than ever
throughout the years the joy your visits
to the United States have brought
Americans and your solidarity with the
American people in times of tragedy have
deepened the friendship and profound
connection between our countries
and Joe and I were so touched by the
generosity and welcome you showed us
when we visited you at Windsor Castle
last year during our first visit
overseas as president and first lady on
behalf of the people of the United
States we send you our best wishes to
you and the people around the world
marking this momentous and historic
occasion
congratulations to your majesty and have
a wonderful Platinum Jubilee celebration
in a statement French president Emmanuel
macron wanted to reminisce about his
country's connection with the Royal
Family
madame
during the past 70 years the president
of the French Republic has relied on
very few constants at the international
level
times have changed Europe has evolved
our continent is again experiencing War
throughout these Transformations your
Devotion to our alliance and to our
friendship hath remained and has helped
build the trust that brought freedom and
prosperity to our continent since your
first state visit to France when you
were welcome to Paris by a generation
who alongside your Army Navy and Air
Force had fought for the freedom we now
enjoy
you have visited us many times
you have shared our Joys and seen the
Deep affection and admiration that the
people of France have for you you have
also visited the graves where so many of
your young men lie and seeing the
respect and honor we constantly pay to
those who sent from your homes to
protect ours
you ask a golden thread that binds our
two countries the proof of the
unwavering friendship between our
Nations your first toast to one of my
predecessors
reminded us that trust and understanding
should endure forever
your words were matched by your lifetime
of Devotion to our alliance
from the dark days when your family
welcomed General the girl in your home
to his joy to welcome you in ease you
have been a constant presence and a
source of wisdom
for the leaders of our two countries
this year the 70s of your Reign we
celebrate your achievements we are
grateful for your courage and we share
the respect and love that the British
people and commonwealths have always
shown you
you're watching the Sarah Jane may show
here on Sky News live from Buckingham
Palace and two days earlier than usual
we'll bring you the details of who has
been named in the Queen's birthday
honors list
[Music]
I'm Dan Whitehead and I'm Sky news's
West of England correspondent
I'm Adam Parsons and Sky's Europe
correspondent based here in Brussels
more flares going off a volley of rocks
problems have been pulled up out and
have been used as missiles for help at
these police
we take you to the heart of stories that
shape our world
[Music]
thank you
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
we have now
Italy and entered France nobody's asked
to check our identity
made by people who dare to challenge
nice to see you again Mr Barney
why committing you
fishing does have the potential to
stymie an enormous economic deal
what strikes you when you come to this
Glacier is not just the way in which the
environment is changing but the speed at
which those changes are happening
it's uh devastating actually
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now the Queen's Jubilee birthday honors
list has been released to celebrate the
incredible Public Service of individuals
across the UK the recipients have been
awarded for their outstanding
contributions across all sectors but in
particular for sustained public service
work on the environment and
sustainability and youth engagement
Skies Ashner reports
so onions
potatoes for seven years Jane has been
taking excess supermarket food and
delivering it to vulnerable people but a
few weeks ago she had a special delivery
of her own she'll be completely
astonished I had to keep looking that it
was actually meant for me the honor of
an Obe last year the project supplied 30
million meals to disadvantaged families
and continues to play a part in solving
the cost of living crisis the honor is
for the whole organization as much as it
is for me I feel and it doesn't make any
difference in how much energy I or
anybody else is going to put into this
amazing wonderful organization
eleven-year-old twins Eleanor and Ruben
are the youngest award recipients
through running challenges they've
raised over 50 000 pounds for the NHS
but they didn't immediately know what
the British Empire medal was I think
it's incredible well one of when I first
found out I didn't I didn't realize how
I am how um how amazing it was my dad
then told me for a bit and then I
realized him how and and how amazing
cool it was it makes us feel really
proud and honorable and we're really
privileged to be here and awarded this
amazing award former England footballer
Rio Ferdinand receives an Obe for his
sporting achievements and charity work
and there's a CV for actor Damien Lewis
for his role as an active campaigner
the horrors of covid-19 may be behind us
but the heroes of the pandemic are still
emerging like 22 year old Alex Griffiths
a healthcare worker who volunteered to
sit with people in hospital as they died
because their families weren't allowed
inside one patient wanted to have her
rosary beads so every time we'd go in
and just reposition her and make sure
she was all okay and everything it was
just making sure she'd given her her
rosary beads back at the end because
that is what brought her comfort for
leading much of the covid-19 response
Professor Stephen Powers receives a
Knighthood for services to the NHS
joining him the former first minister of
Northern Ireland Arlene Foster a sheep
becomes a date I do acknowledge
absolutely the fact that it's about
representation and the fact that I
represented from Alan South Tyrone for
18 years and the fact that I was the
first female first minister in Northern
Ireland so I think it's uh it's actually
to honor all of those things as well but
for me personally it's a huge thrill
securing a place on the Queen's birthday
honors list is always special but
getting one in her Platinum year brings
an extra Sparkle Ashner harinack Sky
News
Eleanor and Ruben totally stealing the
show in that report there from Ashner
Huron right the weather has been very
kind to the start of the Platinum
Jubilee celebrations here in London
let's find out what it has in store for
the rest of the day and the days ahead
warm memories wherever you go
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
high pressure will exert greater
influence over Northern parts of the
country towards the end of the bank
holiday but a warm thundery plume close
to Iberia is likely to bring thundery
showers to the south on Saturday and
Sunday
this afternoon Southern parts of England